this is jockle podcast number 190 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening and joining us
once again is Dave Burke good evening
Dave good evening the last three
podcasts Dave has been on 187 188 and
189 and we have been talking about the
first six chapters of the Marine Corps
publication called one tack three
tactics and if you haven't listened to
those three podcasts go start with those
you'll hear about Dave Burke and if you
have listened to them then we're gonna
continue on today the last the last
podcast of this series hopefully we can
make it through the last two chapters
chapter 7 & 8 Marine Corps 1st
lieutenant at the basic school time now
are they listening and getting anything
out of this particular series of
podcasts based on the number of messages
I get from lieutenants at CBS just
talking about this podcast they are
listening in a way that and and and
learning things that I never learned
when I was at TBS the impact of this on
the Marine Corps is huge because the
fact that a listen of this stuff and
looking at this manual totally
differently than I did 25 years ago
there's um there's just a different way
to observe things through a different
lens than your own and when you're young
a man and listen any of those any first
lieutenant at TBS right now I will trade
places with you immediately if I can do
that I will I will trade places with you
right now I will I would give anything
to be in that position but so it's so so
I'm not trying to disparage your
situation in life what I'm saying is
when you're seeing this for the first
time
you're 21 years old you just don't have
the the breadth of experience to go oh I
can I can relate to that and for me
that's what learning is and I've
complained about this before in schools
in all schools every subject that you
learn in school should be tied with a
thread to every other subject that you
learn in school because it is because
everything that you learn about is tied
to everything else that's that that's
the way it is the science the art the
literature they're all interwoven
through history through mankind and so
what happens is if you can tie those
threads together then you get a better
understanding of what is actually what
you're being taught so what I like and
what why I appreciate the fact that the
young military personnel whether in a
rink or whatever service they're in they
can take what your experiences is Dave
what my experience and we can weave some
other aspects of this information in so
that so that people including me get a
better understanding of of this
knowledge because the knowledge is there
I mean the knowledge is there the
framework is there and I and I'll get to
a point where i i i i I make a critique
of this manual and the critique of this
manual that I make is it's there's a
level of simplicity one that they could
they could make things a little bit
clearer and a little bit more simple a
couple times there's some times where I
think it could be a little bit simpler
in a little bit clean a little bit a
little bit simplified a little bit more
straightforward to be honest with you
that's what I think cover moves simple
prioritizing executing decentralized
commands that is like the the base level
of hey man this is what you need and
then this all just builds so so
perfectly upon that and and of course
there's that's like one situation
there's the other eighty the other 98%
of this is where I look at it oh yeah
they wrote this way better than I ever
could have then Dave then you ever look
and we just don't have and that's what
that's why I even though I said the last
podcast like I know there was there had
to be one guy that was like overseeing
this
but the group of people that put this
thing together they were good at what
they did and and they did a great job
doing this so I'm glad to be able to
talk about it I'm glad to be able to
learn from it and it's amazing because I
don't remember when I read this for the
first time I I don't know I know that
and I was telling you this earlier Dave
when I came back and wrote down the laws
of combat for the first time those were
look I absolutely I know I plagiarized
them from various places but they were
but I didn't I didn't say oh this this
comes from here cover move I know where
I learned that from for the first time I
learned from Roger Haydn was actually
the first time I learn I was like oh
okay well that's the first time I put it
together I'd heard it before that's the
first time I said oh that's what that
actually means the simple thing kind of
the same thing you know some of those
old Vietnam guys did you go to keep the
things simple you know prioritize and
execute that's I had to put a word to I
had to put words to that because I
didn't have I'd never before I wrote
that down I had never told anyone to do
those things I said it in a million
different ways I had said in a million
different ways but I never said okay
this is prioritizing actually that's
what you need to do decentralized
command of isla people been saying that
for a really long time but for me the
first time I wrote him down was when we
got back from Ramadi and I didn't like I
said I knew that I kind of plagiarized
them but at the same time I couldn't
point to the sources right I couldn't
say oh yeah I took this from here I took
that from here I couldn't it was a bunch
of information that was in my head that
had been fermenting for a long period of
time and then when I realized I had to
teach the stuff I I needed to write it
down and it's in a distilled manner so
whim so then when I was tell this this
is the beginning to the part that I was
telling you I was telling you that once
I wrote these four laws I was kind of
like a little bit paranoid because Here
I am you know getting up on a pedestal
and saying hey here's the law
of combat which is a really arrogant
like statement to make right to say oh
I've written the laws of combat but no
like that's not what I'm saying and I
and I questioned as I started putting
them out to guys I started questioning
okay how universally these are these the
right way is this the right way to go is
this the right thing to think about have
I captured these correctly and one of
the ones that I was most concerned about
oddly enough because it's the most
obvious one was simple was keeping
things simple and and part of that
reason was because man the planning had
gotten so completely crazy and out of
control in the SEAL Teams and in the
whole US military the 96-hour planning
cycle it had just gone completely buck
wild crazy and I as a being raised that
way
in the SEAL Teams I had the eye I was a
little nervous about saying to myself
look hey I've been told about all this
detailed planning for the last 15 years
16 years 17 years of my life
and now I'm saying no what you gotta do
is keep it simple and so I started
reading through some of these manuals
that I had skimmed through that I had
looked through that I had that I had
looked down on if you showed me this
manual if I read this manual when I was
in a5 and the teams on urban level in
the games you know that's I'm just being
straight up that's what my attitude
would have been as I started so then
when I referred back to them and I
started going okay let me confirm some
of what I'm saying and when I start with
those so the first one that I really
looked at was simple because I felt like
oh I'm telling guys to be simple but is
that really the right answer and I found
that keeping things simple is a military
maxim of war that has been around since
the beginning of war since the beginning
of war they've been saying hey dumbass
you got to keep things simple and then
from there I continued to read these
different perspectives these different
manuals these different historical
documents and that just the same things
just get repeated
over and over and over and over again
and that's that's why when you hear it
from a different angle a different
perspective and especially one that's
this clearly written it's like yes this
makes up some sense so when I say
there's a little critique I want to make
do I trust me I am NOT making a critique
of like hey listen to me I know alls I'm
saying is like I guess what I'm saying
is this is where I think it fits
together this is where I think you know
being able to explain something to
people from a different just a slightly
different angle it's beneficial and
there's be plenty of people that will go
well you know Jacquizz points okay but
the Marine Corps tactic thing the Marine
Corps manual explains it better and
there's some people that will say oh you
know the Marine Corps tactics thing
makes sense but I actually received it
better one when I heard Dave say this or
I heard Jocko say that like that's so so
when you take these things and you parse
them and you look at them and you look
at them from your viewpoint from my
viewpoint all it does all it does is
gives people a better understanding of
what that intercept understanding does
is it gives you the ability to recognize
these patterns and more in different
places if you've got the humility to
recognize that that that point of view
exists in a whole bunch of different
places
all right extreme ownership at the end
of my career the tail end of my career
and what I learned from that at the time
was significant but more importantly
I've gone back and reread that and
seeing different things in it and I
think the key more than anything is it
actually doesn't matter which of those
ones speak to you the right way it's the
recognition that and it goes back to
when you know the way broadly you see it
in all things if the ability to see
something and read something and have
that teach you something
that you no matter how long you've been
doing it whether you're a second
lieutenant the basic school or a colonel
in the Marine Corps that you will find
these lessons in these different
perspectives in a whole bunch of
different places and what's required is
the humility to recognize it
learn things from a different
perspective and if you keep an open mind
on when you're reading this stuff you'll
go back if you're a lieutenant at TBS
you're gonna read this one three in five
years and it's gonna say totally
different things to you if you go in
with that mindset of you were gonna take
something away from it different than
the first time yeah and the you know we
talked about on the last podcast getting
reps in right getting reps in you know
in whether it's training whether it's
you in an airplane maneuvering around
the sky against an enemy with a wingman
whatever you get reps in and when you
get reps in doing immediate action
drills out in the desert or in the urban
environment you get reps in and then as
a leader you get the reps enough oh
here's something I don't recognize how
can I put my recognition over what I'm
looking at and how can I make a good
decision
you get reps in and the more reps you
get in the better you get
as you go through tactics and you start
to think about it and you start to pick
them apart you start to hear them from
different angles it's a wrap and every
rep you get makes you a little a little
tiny bit better so when I hear the
Marine Corps tactics manual talking
about cooperation and I've been talking
about cover and move consistently for
for a long time let me think for 12
years 13 years I've been talking about
cover move and yet they come in they
call it cooperation it's the same thing
but guess what I know it better now I
have just a little bit more nah I
understand it a little I
I now understand cover move as
cooperation and that's actually the way
I describe it as I said cover moves
teamwork they say cooperation is
teamwork guess what same thing a little
bit different angle I now have a better
understanding of it and that means I'm
gonna be able to recognize it in
different places it what I might not
have I might have seen it in 94
places out of 100 now well now maybe
I'll see you at 96 maybe I'll see at 95
but I'll see it better I'll see it more
clearly so no matter where you are in
your on the path no matter where you are
in the path you're gonna you
gonna see more and Lissa's something
life and I have talked about we like the
first monster or no we did an event with
someone and then they came to the muster
and they said oh I really like the way
you changed the laws of combat and
Leif's like we didn't change we haven't
changed anything as a matter of fact
this the slides that you saw are the
same slides that you saw when you came
to when we came to your company two and
a half years ago or whatever but to your
point what happened to that individuals
his perspective change when he didn't
change but in your purse but that
individuals perspective changes and
that's what you know I always talk about
the the fact that Mike Cirelli when Mike
Cirelli took over the junior officer
course from lathe and I was going in
there with each class and going through
the laws of combat brief and on the 9th
time I taught it when Mike's rally was
running hit and he pulls up a chair in
the back and sits down with his notebook
and I'm like Brody you're gonna sit
through this again and he's like yeah
and I said but why he goes because I I
learned something new every time and you
know you talk about this a lot you talk
about the fact that clients need
repetition yeah and how often how often
do you teach somebody about cover move
or simple or and and they go oh cool got
it it doesn't happen no it doesn't and
it doesn't happen for any of us and even
if you do get it something sinks in it
only sinks in a little bit and then
you've got and this is it's not just so
you seated in what you can actually
teach it different it's another way to
explain the exact same thing knowing
that the people working with you some
will understand it when they see it this
way some understand when they see it
that that way and the more different
ways you can explain it the quicker they
learn to see it in all the other places
that actually will help it really sink
in I don't care who you are
me included none of it sinks in the
first time and even when it does sink in
it's not the whole thing
and to take this one step further
so Jimmy Page my favorite I guess my
favorite example of this is Jimmy Page
the guitarist from Led Zeppelin arguably
the the greatest rock and roll guitarist
of all time who was incredibly beyond
comprehension creative with that
instrument the guitar the get box
he was so creative but he was a studio
musician for many many years and he was
one of the best studio musicians in
London which is no no small feat because
London is a music town so he had this
and when you're a studio musician you
play the notes that they tell you to
play then you play them how you how
they're written on the page there is
100% discipline follow orders you do
what you're told and then guess what
once you have that those standard
operating procedures down then you can
take them in you you can get creative
and you see the patterns where you no
one else sees them
so the same thing the same exact thing
happens with the laws of combat the
better you know them the better you can
take and you can get creative you can
creatively apply them to problems and
and and they overlay properly on those
problems because you understand how to
use them better so I mean I find that a
little clients we've been working for a
long time or clients that have you know
people that read the read the book ten
times red red dichotomy leadership 14
times they've listened to every single
podcast and they'll be presented with a
problem at their job and and the first
thing they do is blame someone the first
thing they do is is make a really
complex solution it's like it's hard to
do now the and and different people
learn at different rates
yeah because we've got clients I've got
clients that could easily teach you
teach teach classes fresh LAN front
because they're so good and their
business is doing great because they've
come so far and they've absorbed so well
and I will tell you right now the
comment rate that every single one of
those those high level
appliers of the laws of combat to their
business everything was like the most
horrible incredibly humble human that is
like oh yeah oh well you know I went to
this school and I've been doing this for
this long yeah and it doesn't matter
because I know I'm not a good leader I'm
gonna get better at it so that's the way
to kick it off now don't go into the
book one tack three tactics well in
chapter seven chapter seven is called
exploiting success and finishing here's
some quotes that starts off with do not
delay in the attack when the foe has
been split off and cut down pursue him
immediately and give him no time to
assemble or form up spare nothing
without regard for difficulties pursue
the enemy day and night until he has
been annihilated
that's Field Marshal Prince Alexander V
Suvarov who is a Russian general who
fought against the Ottoman Empire who
fought against the Polish uprising who
fought in the Italian campaign the
Italian campaign which was actually not
a not a war against the Italians it was
a war against the French it was a war
against Napoleon's army he never
actually came face to face with Napoleon
but he fought him and did very very well
and that's where this next little quote
comes from it says pursue the last man
to the adda and throw the remains into
the river same same guy Field Marshal
Suvarov and that's what he's talking
about
they fight in the French in Italy and
what you do you presume to the a de
river and then you once you've killed
them you Huck their remains into the
river that's the level of finishing that
we're talking about and then the last
quote that they kick this off is when we
have incurred the risk of a battle we
should know how to profit by the victory
and not merely can
tent ourselves according to custom with
possession of the field hey just get in
the field isn't good enough that's not
good enough don't don't don't accept
that and that's Maurice two sacks who
we've covered on this podcast podcast
number 110 reveries on the art of
war.the sacks was a german soldier he
was a he was a leader in the army the
Holy Roman Empire and he ended up being
one of the lead generals of France so
knows what he's talking about and what
he's talking about is just because you
won the field not good enough keep going
and here's how the Marine Corps puts it
it is not enough merely to gain
advantage the enemy will not surrender
simply because he is placed at a
disadvantage
the successful leader exploits any
advantage aggressively and ruthlessly
not once but repeatedly until the
opportunity arises for a finishing
stroke should we just stop the podcast
there
the successful leader exploits any
advantage aggressively and month lessly
not once but repeatedly until the
opportunity arises for a finishing
stroke yeah we must always be on the
lookout for such opportunities whether
we create them in the weather we create
them ourselves or they arise in the flow
of action and when we perceive an
opportunity to be decisive we must seize
it the application of marine corps
tactics does not mean that we expect to
win effortlessly or bloodlessly or that
we expect the enemy to collapse just
because we outmaneuver him
it means we look for and make the most
of every advantage and apply the
decisive stroke when the opportunity
presents itself building on the
advantage once we have gained the
advantage we exploit it we use it to
create new opportunities we then exploit
those opportunities to create others
shaping the flow of action to our
advantage this is so much jiu-jitsu its
dick Ulis I mean it's so much everything
but the direct correlation to jujitsu is
just crazy even small favoring
circumstances exploited repeatedly and
aggressively can quickly multiply into
son into decisive advantages this is
when you're rolling with Dean Lister and
you give him part of one quarter of an
inch of arm position and he gets it and
and you think well you know that no big
deal it's just a quarter of an inch in
arm position and then he exploits that
small circumstance repeatedly and
aggressively until he's got your arm
he's ripping it off your body that's
what I'm talking about
well back to the book like the chess
grandmaster one we must think ahead to
our next move and one beyond how am I
going to use this advantage to create
another one for example an attack by
penetration once we have created one
advantage by punching through the
enemy's position and getting to his rear
we create another by pouring forces
through the gap generating the expanding
torrent that Liddell Hart wrote about
you keep going relentless attack yeah
and those those windows those
opportunities not only are they fleeting
like those aren't gonna be seconds
sometimes that that opportunity is
actually there before he figures out a
way to prevent that from happening all
the other resources that you need to
bring to bear for that have to be ready
to go so these things that they're
describing as simple as their disguise
look for an opport those windows are
really really small and when you see
them you might get one in an entire
fight you might get one maybe two you
have to have all those other things that
you need to win ready to go and fill
that unrelenting until the end they are
making em they're describing a very
simple way but man that is to see that
and exploit that too they finish yeah
and I'm not to me sometimes the the
people will talk about like how the
importance of mindset right this is one
of those things what you just said is
like you have to have the mindset pre
prior to the opening happening you have
to be thinking as soon as I see this I
am going and if you don't have that the
split second that it takes you to look
at it and go wait I think that's an
opening I think I should go the old
girl's gone so having that proactive and
pre-existing mentality of when I see
this I'm going you know you see kids
wrestling and shooting takedowns like
that's what they're doing they are so
pre-planned to once they do that setup
and that that counter starts to take
place and they see that boom they're in
there there's no thought process going
and if you think about it for one
millisecond that opportunities alone
rommel recounts how exploiting each
advantage in the battle for cook in the
Carpathian Mountains during World War
one led to another opportunity as his
detachment exploited each situation and
moved further behind enemy lines it
generated more surprise and advantage
during this actions during this action
were almost detachment captured
thousands of enemy soldiers with very
little fighting due largely to his
unwillingness to lose momentum one
success led directly to another
opportunity which he seized immediately
and that's from that's from one almost
book attacks infantry attacks which is a
great book we haven't covered it on here
yet it's super tactical it is super
tactical it is like talking about where
to maneuver squads it's that tactical
well it's good about it and when I
covered on the podcast every section in
that book has a little a little
italicized last three four paragraphs
that explain what just happened like hey
here's it's it's not a white like a full
lessons learned it's not quite
hey here's the let take away from this
eat but some of them are pretty close so
when I cover it attacks infantry attacks
on here probably do that but that's what
we're talking about I'm not gonna slow
down I'm not gonna stop the people when
we work with companies and they have
these really good business leaders that
were working with CEOs or guys are just
in the game that's how they are
that's how there are everywhere in their
life everything in their life is like
they are always looking everywhere in
life for those little fleeting
opportunities and they are so they are
so triggered and ready to attack those
positions when they reveal themselves
it's and you talk about the mindset it
when you see it done and it permeates
all aspects of people's lives and they
look for those windows everywhere and
it's something you actually have to you
don't want to look back on your life and
think of all the times that you missed
to attack whatever opportunity was there
and think about how often that happens
but just think about the guys that we
work with the ones that are really good
it's not just at work and they're like
some different person it's like that all
the time yeah
and obviously what can we screw up here
we can attack every up every sin that we
see that's the dichotomy so the more
experienced you are as a leader the
better you can the better you can see
the pattern recognition then you
recognize what opportunities are good
and what somebody asked me this the
other day like you what opportu you sort
through all these opportunities you know
and for me I definitely mean I get a lot
of opportunities and which ones am I
gonna invest time into what's the and
here's the here's what the answer is
did they answer that question is okay
how much investment is gonna take from
me timewise because I don't have enough
time to do everything that I want to do
it makes me mad but I don't and so and
then what's the return on investment
gonna be how is it interact and support
every other thing that I've got going on
because I'm not gonna go and start some
venture that's outside that doesn't
positively support everything else that
I'm doing
the pieces that fit in it everything
else I make everything else better those
are the ones that you have to attack on
the ones that fit in everywhere else in
your life yeah
after the battle for Tarawa in November
major Henry Crowe commanding officer of
2nd battalion 8th Marines was asked why
he thought the Japanese had been
defeated so quickly once the Marines
were established to shore he remarked
that it was due to the constant pressure
of naval gunfire bombs and mortars the
Marines used their advantage in
supporting arms to create opportunities
for success that pressure putting that
pressure on when you put the pressure on
that's what creates the opportunities
that's what you feel that one in jujitsu
all day long Andy was working me over on
the mat yesterday constant pressure
constant attack it was me just trying to
fill in the gaps as they were opening up
and how long can you fill in the gaps
for you you can't do it indefinitely
because when you're filling in one gap
guess what's happening another gap is
opening up and so you got to be careful
that that's the going back to what we
just talked about like if you try and
fill gaps that don't that aren't good
opportunities
you're leaving other areas exposed and
that's gonna be a negative next sections
called consolidation exploitation and
pursuit once we have created leverage
how do we take full advantage of it a
decisive result or victory rarely stems
from the initial action no matter how
successful more often victories are the
result of aggressively exploiting some
relative advantage until one becomes
decisive and the action turns into a
rout victories are the result of
aggressively exploiting some relative
advantage until one becomes decisive
casualty rates historically tend to
remain constant and often fairly even
until one side or the other tries to
flee only then do significantly
asymmetrical casualty rates commonly
occur this exploitation of the enemy's
bad situation can yield surprising
great results we can take several
specific types of actions to exploit
opportunities we have created or
discovered the first way we can exploit
successes by consolidation as we
consolidate our forces after seizing a
position we intend to hold against the
enemy here our aims are limited to
protecting what we have already gained
we must realize that by consolidating
rather than continuing to force the
issue
we may be surrendering the initiative
that's talking a holding position there
are there may be any number of reasons
for choosing this course perhaps we lack
the strength to continue to advance our
new gain may be may be of critical
importance and the risk of losing it
outweighs the advantages of any further
gains perhaps the new gain itself grants
a significant advantage for instance the
position that provides excellent fires
or threatens the enemy lines of
communications may put the enemy in an
untenable position perhaps the new gain
compels the enemy to meet us on our
terms for example we seize a critical
piece of terrain with a strong - with
strong defensive qualities forcing the
enemy to attack on unfavorable terms so
there are times where you hold position
there are times when you strong Boyd you
you can solid eight your forces you get
everyone together you you you dig in
there are absolutely times to do that
and they say - and if you do that too
long that can stifle the the initiative
end and I need I think about this
sometimes is that and I I need to be
more careful sometimes and I think about
this even with clients that I work with
every time I say something I know that
there's a dichotomy to what I'm saying
that there is no absolute and I
sometimes it forget to say and if you
push too aggressively you can get too
spread out every everything that's being
said here and all the conversations were
having
make it good by definition there is a
dichotomy at all but you can go too far
in any of these directions so as you
read this and listen to these things and
even the things that I say we don't
always talk about what the dichotomy is
but that's a perfect example of hey we
can consolidate that might be the right
thing to do but if we do that too much
we lose the advantage we have of how
fast I order over there our tempo is and
it worked too aggressive and get to
spread out too thinned out down the line
then that can be a problem too there's a
dichotomy in every action that we can
take as a leader and I know that in my
head and I don't always articulate and
say that but that's the way we should
think in all the movements no matter how
aggressive we're gonna be to remember
you can overdo all of this stuff yeah
well that's one of the reasons we we
wrote the dichotomy of leadership is
because and I when I first started
talking about the dichotomy leadership I
would say it was because a lot of
questions we got were about the
dichotomy leadership but the real reason
we wrote is because the answers are
about the dichotomy a leadership yes and
every and it's it's a and and I talked
about this already on this series of
podcasts that that the reason one of the
things that brought the dichotomy of
leadership to my brain was the fact that
what was was I had to admit that I was
wrong I had to say you know what being
aggressive be aggressive be aggressive
be aggressive and and then I realized oh
that can be wrong oh you can be too
aggressive yes you can
oh you can strong point to building too
long and that was something we'd see all
the time in training was we'd we'd be
attacking guys in an urban environment
they would do the right thing and strong
point of building and if they got bogged
down in that building then they would
get surrounded and they get picked off
and they'd get slaughtered if they
strong pointed that building they made a
quick rapid plan on how they were gonna
break out of there they would do fine so
they had to find that they had to find
that balance
the second way to pursue an advantage is
through exploitation an offensive tactic
that is designed to disorganize enemy in
depth exploitation usually follows a
successful attack that is created or
exposed some enemy vulnerability for
example an attack that is torn a gap in
enemy defenses allows us to attack vital
enemy areas the object of exploitation
is not to destroy the combat forces
directly opposing us even though they
may be weakened instead the object is to
disrupt the entire enemy system by
attacking important activities and
functions it's real easy to get
distracted into the little tactical
battle that you could win as opposed to
looking at what's going on strategically
and how you can attack you how you can
disrupt the entire enemy system in
Desert Storm there was sure most people
further there's something called the
highway of death and there was this
string of enemy armored vehicles that
went for miles and miles and miles up
into into Iraq at a Kuwait and that
started and I don't know a hundred
percent of the story but it started with
this formation of fighter attack
aircraft that under most circumstances
you would hit that lead element that's
the tactical smart thing to do it
preserves the most amount of fuel it's
the best for your weapons and they
actually bypassed that lead formation
and went all the way to the tail end of
the formation so rather than just
disrupt that where the point of attack
was at that lead element where our
forces had met their forces and actually
bypassed that one all the way to the
tail end of that enemy formation and
devastated that tail end and blocked the
road hmm and that allowed for the next
30 hours wave and wave and wave of
aircraft who then pick off every other
vehicle that had no place to maneuver by
bypassing what seemed to be the most
obvious answer which is that first line
which they recognize this is our
opportunity to shut this whole system
down and that was the genesis of that is
recognizing this is the area we need to
exploit and we're I should to take it
we're going to skip the tactical answer
here and go all the way to the end of
this form
and that created a route that the enemy
couldn't recover from because they had
nowhere to go because those guys saw the
opportunity to do that at the very
beginning of that campaign whereas
mostly I think you got first element
come back do it again and that gives
them all that time to turn to
recalibrate and do something different
yeah and especially and I don't I don't
know too much about that scenario from
the air perspective but from the ground
perspective you would think well the
lead element is the one that you're most
worried about they're the ones that are
closest to friendly forces we need to go
and eliminate them first and we'll go
from there so to sort of bypass that is
a pretty bold decision to make
continuing on for example during
Operation Desert Storm in 1991 the
Army's Tiger brigade was deployed by the
2nd Marine Division as an exploitation
force during the divisions final attack
the brigade had the advantage over the
Iraqis in speed firepower and night
combat capabilities with these
advantages the tiger brigade sliced deep
into the rear of the Iraqi 3 Corps and
sealed off the vital highway
intersections north of al-zahraa the
result was total disruption in the Iraqi
organiz organized defense the third way
to exploit advantages through pursuit a
pursuit is an offensive tactic designed
to cut off or catch a hostile force that
has lost cohesion and is attempting to
escape in order to destroy it if the
intent is to bring about the final
destruction or capture of the enemy
forces then pursuit should be pushed
with utmost vigor it is here that
operations turn into routes and
overwhelming victories often occur
general Grant's pursuit of General Lee's
Confederate Army of Northern Virginia
from Petersburg from Petersburg to
Appomattox in April 1918 65 is a classic
example of pursuit here grant pushed his
forces to their limits in order to
prevent Lee's escape this ultimately led
to the capture and surrender of Lee's
forces the Confederate
armies Lieutenant General Thomas J
Stonewall Jackson summed up pursuit when
he said strike the enemy and overcome
him never give up the pursuit as long as
your men have the strength to follow for
an enemy routed if hotly pursued becomes
panic-stricken and can be destroyed by
half their number so you once you've got
them on the run run them down run them
down finishing the enemy ultimately we
want to cultivate opportunities into a
decisive advantage once we do we make
the most of it Marine Corps tactics call
for leaders who are strong finishers we
must have a strong desire to go for the
jugular I'm so thankful they put that in
there because that's that's you know
usually that's sort of like a like a
ruffian comment to make right it's
usually said in a negative way like dude
I can't believe you went for the jugular
like yeah a disproportionate response
yeah yeah yeah
no no we're talking that's the right
response so we're gonna do go for the
jugular
we must be constantly trying to find and
create the opportunity to deliver the
decisive blow at the same time we must
not be premature in our actions oh they
should call this the dichotomy of
leadership we must not make the decisive
move before the conditions are right
yeah when you guys talk about the idea
of being aggressive though you described
as use the phrase default aggressive
that doesn't say be aggressive 100% of
the time there are times not to do that
absolutely but really what this is
talking about is the type of mindset you
want to cultivate is that that's gonna
be my default unless I have to I want to
pull the reins back on my guys at the
time to say no no this is not the time
to do it I don't want to be in a
position to say hey look change your
default and get aggressive now and start
pushing them into that breach so that is
actually right that's the default and
then there are times have you
now because there's other things that
player that maybe we you don't see and I
might see from up here that they're
pulling you into that we don't want to
go on that direction but the default
actually I want every one of my guys to
be aggressive and I'll pull them back as
opposed to well I thought the best thing
to do was hold off until you told me to
go that's the default that will get you
killed which is not being aggressive so
it doesn't say be dressed of a 100 cent
of the time but your default needs to be
in that position yeah and what's what's
the reason that's necessary is because
the moment the split-second that it
takes to tell someone okay now we're
gonna turn on our aggressiveness windows
gone the windows gone and counter to
that in the moment that it takes to sell
someone hey actually we're not gonna do
that they go okay cool it's not that big
of a deal they didn't miss an
opportunity they they started their
exploitation and then they said oh we're
gonna pull back fine no factor no factor
one works the other does not work period
this ability to finish the enemy once
and for all derives from first from
possessing an aggressive mentality
second it stems from an understanding of
the commander's intent third it stems
from a keen situational awareness that
helps recognize opportunities when they
present themselves and understand when
the conditions are right for action so
again it's not 100 percent of the time
it's when the conditions are right for
action so those those are the three
things first aggressive mentality second
understanding the commander's intent
third situational awareness so you
understand if the actions are right next
section use of the reserve in combat the
reserve is an important tool for
exploiting success the reserve is part
of the commander's combat power
initially withheld from action in order
to influence future action the reason to
create and maintain a reserve is to
provide flexibility to deal with the
uncertainty chance and disorder of war
the reserve is thus a valuable tool for
maintaining adaptability in general the
more uncertain the situation the larger
should be in reserve
Napoleon once said that war is composed
of nothing but accidents and a general
should never lose sight of anything
everything to enable him to profit from
those accidents these accidents take the
form of opportunities and crisis's at
crises the reserve is a key tactical
tool for dealing with both the commander
should have a purpose in mind for
reserve employment and design it to
fulfill that purpose to truly exploit
success may warrant assignment of the
commander's best subordinate unit or a
preponderance of combat power or
mobility assets to the reserve so
sometimes you're you Reserve should be
your strongest and most powerful element
whether it's the best or whether it's
the the one with the most combat power
those commanders who properly organize
tasks and equip their reserves are
usually the ones with the capability to
finish the enemy when the opportunity
arises Winston Churchill recognize the
value of a reserve when he wrote it is
in the use and withholding of their
reserves that great commanders have
generally excelled after all when once
the last reserve has been thrown in
commanders the commander's part is
played the event must be left to pluck
and to the fighting troops and pluck is
like an old term for courage basically
once you've put committees your reserve
you're done you've made your move you
made your move and now you gotta let it
go you gotta do you you you you don't
have much influence over it anymore
and always important to keep that keep
that reserve strong always important
financial reserve that's a big one to
think about and we deal with companies
and they're weighing out the risk
because sometimes like we need to go
all-in right now and when you commit the
reserve that can be the decisive moment
back to the book a strong reserve is
also a way to retain the initiative if
an advance slows the reserve can
increase moment
if in advance picks up speed the
commitment of the reserve then Ken can
then create a route we may use the
reserve to expand or exploit gaps or
penetrations we may commit the reserve
to attack in a different location thus
exploiting opportunities for success
instead of reinforcing failure without a
strong reserve even the most promising
opportunities can be lost a classic
example of the use of reserve is the
battle for taru WA with the 2nd and 8th
marine regiments held up on the assault
beaches general Julian Smith decided to
land the 6th Marine Regiment that is the
division reserve to break the stalemate
the 1st battalion 6th Marines which was
tasked organized as part of the division
reserve landed on the western end of the
island passed through the 3rd battalion
2nd Marines and from the flank conducted
a swift and violent assault of the
Japanese fortifications across the
island within 48 hours the Japanese
forces were nigh elated and the island
secured when you're training the jujitsu
would you know what you considered what
do you consider your reserve echo when
you're training or jujitsu what I mean
energy reserve or see that's what I
think of yes essentially athleticism is
a reserve right we're less that's one
reserve and one reserve you have is
energy right how much energy do you have
oh yeah no we wouldn't even commit that
yeah cuz let's face it if you commit
your energy really early on against a
fruitless attack yeah
you're gonna run out of energy you're
talking about a wipeout right now you're
talking about me that's what I know the
most about is not I wish I knew it's
that 30 seconds into it I'm too tired -
exhausted I've overexerted myself when
almost always my coach will when will
replay it there was no reason to do it
there was no thing that I was triggering
like this is the time to to to apply my
exertion
yeah I mean that's what you're talking
about someone who doesn't know when to
when to do that and when they don't know
they do it at all the wrong times yeah
that's that's the way I feel when I roll
I feel like I'm I have a good reserve
yeah I feel like I maintain my reserves
and I don't commit them unless it's time
yeah yeah if you can consciously be
aware and yeah the earlier on you are
the harder it is for you to control it
more than anything we're like yeah
you're you know chocolate your level is
like you almost not even consciously can
control that you know it's like it's
almost like you're you're subconsciously
triggered to like okay you know like
this is maybe this this match or this
this training whatever is heating up so
let me maintain the reserves right now
you know kind of thing you'll still use
your technique yeah yeah for sure when
the guy is bringing it it's kind of like
dang you got a fight his energy with
your energy you're like okay I'm not
gonna do that I might take a guard pass
or something like that and save it till
it tell that's really true and at the
end of the day that's really the the
reserve
it's the reserve even if you say
athleticism or strength or muscle in it
because your last-ditch effort all that
takes energy yeah and that's essentially
what you're using your using technique
takes energy yeah and let's face it if
you had unlimited energy yeah then you
would just win yeah I mean unless you're
going to get someone that's just
technically vastly superior to you yeah
yeah and when you're in a battle in a
barrack in a battle you've got one
reserved and it is that the energy
sometimes we must employ the reserve to
deal with some crisis rendering it
temporarily unavailable for commitment
elsewhere in such instances a reserve
should be reconstituted as rapidly as
possible so sometimes you got a scramble
you know and move and use some energy
and then as soon as you get to a good
position to rest we should look for the
opportunity to employ the reserve to
reinforce success however we may employ
the reserve
however we employ we may employ the
reserve we should always think of it as
the tool for clinching victory that's
also why you see a guy
gets us gets a submission thinks let me
rephrase that a guy thinks he gets his
submission and expends all of his energy
trying to clinch the victory expends all
of his reserves you see this in MMA a
lot too it spends all of his reserves
has nothing left the person gets out of
the the possible submission and the game
is now the tides turns it and in this
respect marshall faulk who is a french
general he was actually the supreme
Allied commander in World War one
leading troops to victory at them at the
Marne which I don't know man
a guy like every time I read like the
background of a general or of someone
that's getting quoted I'm always like
yeah there you go but when you were the
in charge of all allies in World War one
no offense I'm not super I'm not super
stoked on what you have to say cuz cuz
yeah anyways he wrote that the reserve
is a club prepared organized reserved
carefully maintained with a view to
carrying out one act of battle from
which a result is expected the decisive
attack it is generally and then that's
the end of his quote which I'm glad I
said I wasn't too impressed with him
because I wasn't impressed with that
quote is that just my own bias do I hate
World War one that much no it's because
all the other things we've talked about
in the last four podcasts about
requirements to be successful in combat
or almost all missing yeah the
creativity all those things have you
talked about the human wave advancement
to steal seventy-five yards from the
enemy only to give it up at sunset was
none of those things so I had the exact
same response in my mind you know that
quotes over it is generally through
offensive action even in the defense
that we achieve decisive results since
the reserve represents our bid to
achieve a favorable decision or to
prevent an unfavorable one it often
becomes the main effort once
and should be supported by all of their
elements of force along with the
tangible assets used as a reserve the
prudent commander must also be aware of
and planned for the intangible factors
that impact on combat power and its
sustainment intangible factors include
fatigue that's number one it doesn't say
this is an order
but that's number one and by the way
that's what we've been talking about
fatigue we've been talking about energy
but the opposite of energy is fatigue so
number one fatigue number two leadership
quality no surprise number three
proficiency number four morale
number five teamwork number six
equipment maintenance we build reserves
also by reserving aviation sortie rates
or numbers withholding unique or low
density munitions or holding critical
supplies such as fuel or petroleum oils
and lubricants for a specific goal we
consider these intangible factors when
creating and tasking the reserve as we
do in all assignments of tasks yeah and
this is again this is what businesses
have to think about all the time because
you do not know what the market is gonna
do I don't care who you are I don't care
how long you've been doing this for you
don't know what the markets gonna do you
can you have good suspicions that's
great
you don't know big difference yeah it's
actually telling you to be extremely
disciplined they use the term a load
density that just means something you
don't have a lot of you know low density
high demand items in the military or
these really unique capabilities
different types of aircraft and weapons
but you don't have a lot of them so you
have to be really disciplined with their
use so when the time is actually right
to use them they're available to you to
use them incredible concept these
concepts apply not only to units
initially designated as a reserve but
also to any unit since any unit can be
shifted or recommitted as the reserve
thus a commander must always be mentally
prepared to redesign eight roles of
units and to create and use reserves as
the situation
wires I knew it you know what's
interesting is we see this we see these
these businesses that end up eating
other businesses is that the right word
acquiring I guess but but basically when
you get a business that maintains a
solid reserve when opportunity reveals
itself
they're there to cash in yeah and buy
other companies and take them over and
then they come out of that you know if
you don't maintain reserve the
opportunities there
you can't exploit it same thing with
your leadership capital right same thing
with you as a leader if you sit there
and you expend all your leadership
reserve all your leadership capital you
don't leave any reserve you have no more
for lack of a better word you have no
more favors to ask as a leader should
you be asking favors yeah you are asking
for favors that's what every time you
ask a subordinate do something you're
asking for a favor that's what you're
asking you're asking them to put their
trust in you to do this thing that you
want that's a favor and if you expend
all your leadership capital you have no
more favors to ask when the time is
needed and you've expended those
reserves you're not gonna be followed
anymore that's why relationships are so
critical to all this I mean that's how
you build up your that's your leadership
reserve that's your capital that's your
reserve force is how strong those
relationships are so when the time is
right you can cash in on that
not that you cash in on them and use
them as some sort of expendable
resources that you actually leverage
that relationship as that recognition
that you need to build that now you
don't know when you're gonna need it but
you're gonna need it and I say this
answer the question all the time with
company is about needing to wrote the
crisis that you're dealing with now
that's not you can't start there and if
you haven't built it up the reality is
is there's really no answer I can give
you because if you don't have anything
and reserves it's very little you can do
to leverage to try to solve this problem
what you need to do is think about it
well in advance and the strengths of
those relationships from you
contributing to them is how you have
something left in reserve when you need
it people want to know what to do get
this all the time I'm flying against
another aircraft he's directly behind
me at a thousand feet and he's about to
shoot his gun at me what do I do
might you know what there's not I know
I'm a top constructor here but I don't
have a lot of good answers for you you
have nothing left available to utilize
here to defend yourself against the
situation the answer is you got to go
back to the beginning which you can't do
and people want the solution then and
the solution is you you got to go back
you got to build capital in other ways
before you get to that position
yeah that's like how do you escape the
rear naked choke yeah you know is it
possible sure the other person can make
a mistake you could you could do
something but the bottom line is you get
someone gets a legit rear naked choke on
you or someone gets you in the Triangle
there's there's a way to get out it's
called submitting this is the conclusion
of this chapter most decisive victories
do not result from the initial action
but from quickly and aggressively
exploiting the opportunities created by
that action we may find any number of
ways to exploit tactical opportunity but
they all have the same object to
increase leverage until we find until we
have the final opportunity to decide the
issue once and for all in our favor a
goal and Marine Corps tactics is not
merely to gain advantage but to boldly
and ruthlessly exploit that advantage to
achieve final victory and now we will
get to the eighth and final chapter of
marine corps tactics and it is called
you might think that these guys sitting
around in a room writing doctrine would
come up with more doctrinally doctrine
sounding things things that things that
they would come up with that in the in
the halls of academia right you might
think that what do they call chapter 8
they call it making it happen that
passes muster so making it happen
chapter 8 here's the quotes it starts
off with 9/10 of tactics are
certain and taught in books but the
irrational tenth is like the Kingfisher
flashing across the pool and that is the
test of generals it can only be ensured
by instinct sharpened by thought
practicing the strokes so often that the
that at the crisis it is as natural as a
reflex and that's by TE Lawrence
Lawrence of Arabia nine tenths of
tactics are certain I look the
irrational tenth there's a tenth of
tactics that are irrational and this is
where you become this is why if you
can't tap into that creativity if you
can't train that creativity in your
brain that's why you're not going to be
successful well I shouldn't say you're
not going to be eminently successful
you'll be somewhat successful you'll be
reliable and that's admirable it's good
to be reliable but if you want to go
next level you need to be able to be a
little bit irrational at times to be to
be able to handle the irrational and the
next quote is it cannot be too often
repeated that in modern war and
especially in modern naval war the chief
factor in achieving triumph is what has
been done in the way of thorough
preparation and training before the
beginning of the war which is which is
what you were talking about David like
why are you in that position and that's
by by the way that's Teddy Roosevelt
Theodore Roosevelt President Theodore
Roosevelt Rough Rider Theodore Roosevelt
Medal of Honor recipient Theodore
Roosevelt who by the way his son Teddy
Roosevelt jr. Medal of Honor recipient
d-day you know old he was at d-day you
know old Teddy that young junior was on
d-day when he was present on the beach
in Normandy Oh
56 years old 56 years old demanded that
he be allowed to lead his men into that
situation and and he was not he was not
like a strong healthy 56 years old you
wanna know why he wasn't strong and
healthy at the age of 56 because he was
still having problems health major
health problems from the wounds that he
suffered in World War 1 so there you go
there's the quotes these are quotes we
listened to and going to the book
reading and understanding the ideas in
this publication are the initial steps
on the road to tactical accident
excellence reading and understanding boy
they throw those words out there real
easy don't they reading and
understanding as if it's like if you
read you understand that is not true
reading and understanding have almost
nothing to do with each other reading
and understanding that should be
capitalized and italicized and in the
different font reading and understanding
the ideas in this publication are the
initial steps such as the initial steps
on the road to tactical accidents
excellence the primary way a marine
leader becomes an able tactician is
through training and education both of
which are firmly rooted in doctrine
doctrine establishes the philosophy and
the practical framework for how we fight
education develops the understanding
creativity military judgment and the
background essential for effective
battlefield leadership there is a lot to
learn training follows doctrine and
develops the tactical and technical
proficiency that underlies all
successful military action individual
and group exercises serve to integrate
training and education producing a whole
that is greater than the sum of its
parts
the lessons learned from training and
operational experience then
modify doctrine doctrine next section
doctrine doctrine establishes the
fundamental beliefs of the Marine Corps
on the subject of war and how we
practice our profession doctrine
establishes a particular way of thinking
about war and our way of fighting a
philosophy for leading Marines in combat
a mandate for professionalism and a
common language that is important that's
one of the things when we work with
companies the common language part these
companies know that they're making
mistakes they don't know how do I
properly identify what their mistakes
are or what their issues are until we
come in and we start teaching them about
cover and move about simple but
prioritize and execute about the
centralized command about default
aggressive they they they are they know
there's a problem but they can't put
their finger on it and then once they
once we come and they can put their
finger on it and then they can talk
about it in a common language that's
like the initial foothold in victory is
actually being able to communicate with
each other about what the damn problem
is doctrinal development benefits from
our collective experience and distills
its lessons to further education and
training our doctrine within the Marine
Corps
begins with the philosophy contained in
Marine Corps doctrinal publication one
which is called war fighting which we
covered on this podcast early on that
was one of the earliest ones I covered
and that's the reason because that one
is a good solid foundation a good solid
philosophy for doctrine for war fighting
this publication underlies this
philosophy underlies publications in the
Marine Corps war fighting publication
series that contain tactics techniques
and procedures for specific functions
the body of thought helps form Marine
tactician
through its implementation in education
and training now they have this little
diagram and there's been some other
diagrams which I didn't really try to
explain too much because
you can get the book it's free it's a
PDF but this one has it has this loop
the loop has education it has training
it has operational employment
it has doctrine and they all so you you
get educated you go train you employ
operationally that operational
employment becomes doctrine the doctrine
is what we teach on so so there's the
doctrinal development cycle and what I
added into this little thing is that in
between each of those steps you adapt
you assess and you adjust so that's
what's happening you educate and as you
educate then you go train well when you
train you're gonna make adaptations
you're gonna make assessment you're
gonna make adjustments then when you
deploy and employ you're gonna do the
same thing you're going to assess where
you're out what worked what didn't
you're gonna make adaptations and you're
gonna put that in the doctrine with a
doctrine you're gonna take that and
educate people and you're gonna
continually assess and adapt and adjust
what you're what you're teaching and
what you're training on next section
education while combat provides the most
instructive lessons on decision making
that's an understatement of the year
while combat provides the most
instructive lessons on decision making
tactical leaders cannot wait for war to
begin their education we must be
competent in our profession before our
skills are called upon the lives of our
Marines depend on it our education and
tactics must develop three qualities
within all tactical leaders the first
quality is creative ability tactical
leaders must be encouraged to devise and
pursue unique approaches to military
problems no rules governing ingenuity
see now this is not what people expect
we did the disappeared do we did the
chapter on discipline and this seems to
be completely counter to that that's why
there's a dichotomy here but the number
one quality to develop is creative
ability and there's no rules that govern
ingenuity
the line separating bold list boldness
from fool hardiness is drawn by the hand
of practical experience that said an
education and tactics must possess an
element of rigor too often tactical
discussions lacking an in-depth analysis
of cause and effect the tactically
proficient leader must learn how to
analyze solutions to tactical problems
lacking such a rigorous analysis the
tactician will not learn from experience
nor exercise creative ability this
applies to everything by the way it
applies to everything anything that
you're trying to learn you should you
should you should focus on this attitude
of really truly doing in-depth analysis
and and making sure that you're not just
learning how to apply the techniques as
they were taught but how to apply them
as they were not taught creatively the
second quality is military judgment
which includes the skills for gaining
situational awareness and acting
decisively the tactician must readily
recognize the critical factors in any
situation enemy capabilities weather
terrain characteristics and the
condition of our own forces to mention
just a few
marine leaders must be able to cut to
the heart of a situation by identifying
its important elements developing a
sound plan and making clear decisions
our educational approach should
emphasize the ability to understand the
mission issue clear intent and determine
the main effort now for all the first
lieutenant's at the basic school and all
the other young officers and NCOs that
are out there that when when they talk
about the tactician must readily
recognize the critical factors in any
situation I promise you that if you want
to be able to do that what you need to
learn how to do is to detach from the
situation is to take a step back when
there's enemy capabilities that you have
to understand when there's terrain when
there's when there's maneuvering
elements that you need to understand
and recognize you will not be able to do
that if you are staring down your ACOG
or staring down your iron sights or
you've got your helmet pressed up
against your radar in an f-18 you will
not see what you need to see so learn to
detach get your head on a swivel take a
step back this will make you infinitely
better infinitely better then the same
you if you're sucked into your weapon
system the sir the sooner you learn the
ability to do that the amount of a
leadership advantage you have by being
able to do that in the most difficult
situations is its I don't have the words
it's not even fair it's it's not that's
right it's not even fair you will be
head and shoulders and the reason I say
that with a little funny tone is because
I remember I had a guy that was in t you
bruiser and he was a platoon commander
and I was putting him through training
and it was like some scenario unfolding
and I was like I was like bro come here
I'm like just just come with me over
here over here was like six inches away
and I'm like look around and it was so
obvious I'm like hey man if you can be 1
inch if you can be 1 inch at altitude
above everyone else you can see you can
see a thousand times more what they can
see a thousand times more so if you want
to be able to have that situational
awareness you have to learn how to
detach
the third quality is moral courage moral
courage is the ability to make and carry
out the decision regardless of personal
cost it is different from and rarer than
physical courage the cost of physical
courage may be injury or death whereas
the cost of moral courage may be the
loss of friends popularity prestige or
career opportunities the burden of
conflicting responsibilities in combat
responsibility for lives of subordinates
support for peers loyalty disappears and
duty to nation can be heavy our
educational efforts should lead
potential leaders to work through the
proper resolution of such conflicts in
peacetime leaders often need to make
morally correct decisions in combat but
there will rarely be time for deep moral
or ethical contemplation on the
battlefield now what's interesting about
this is first of all they say it's rarer
than physical courage and then it says
the cost of physical courage may be
injury or death - to most people that
sounds like the worst thing is possible
but then they're saying but whereas the
cost of moral courage may be loss of
friends popularity prestige and this is
the one I find most interesting or
career opportunities so what they are
saying right there I mean obviously if
my boss wants me to make a certain
correct moral decision he's gonna
promote me but what they're saying in
that statement right there that there
are times when you will be making
decisions that are morally correct that
will actually hurt your career that's
the statement or you will be at risk of
hurting your career I can think of a
thousand examples of this right off the
top of my head from being in SEAL
platoons you know because you you you
want that what happens to leaders
sometimes in a seal platoon is they
don't want it they're insecure about
their leadership and there's something
going on that they do
feel comfortable about but they don't
have the moral courage to say anything
and part of that is because hey they
they say oh this is this shouldn't be
happening and as soon as they say that
they're drawing a spotlight on
themselves and they're not really sure
about themselves and all of a sudden
they feel like if their boss is gonna
look at them like they don't know how to
lead their men and now I'm not gonna get
promoted like that whole thing on once
your life and I were talking yesterday
and you know he was like hey you told me
I was he was saying that I told him like
if you don't do this you're failing as a
leader and and what he realized was much
of what life babban had in his head was
correct but he just didn't really have
the confidence yet to say just to - to
them - to implement you know to
implement it until I was a hey man if
you allow this to happen that that's
actually you being a bad leader whether
it was you know and I'm just talking
about anything any anything that you dis
you you know what's right you know
what's wrong or at least you have a
strong suspicion okay you know what this
doesn't seem right to me but I'm not
really convicted of some it's not gonna
say anything I'll just let it kind of
let it go and that is wrong and that's
what takes this moral courage to step up
when you're gonna be unpopular when
you're gonna be the guy that says hey
guess what we're not gonna do that and
in the team is a lot of it is you're
you're a pussy you're a wimp if you
don't if all you just need to get on
board with what we're doing here so no
actually I don't
we're actually gonna do what the right
thing is here legally
most of the catastrophic events that I
saw in my career weren't on the
battlefield weren't getting beat in
combat or outmaneuver by an enemy most
of the catastrophic events were teams
squadrons what-have-you that had leaders
that allowed those things to happen and
build over time because they were afraid
to get involved and eventually something
catastrophic gonna happen inside that
team that ironically ended up being a
reflection of their leadership anyway so
they were most afraid of was what
culminated anyways reflection of their
leadership allowing those questionable
ethical behaviors those questionable
ways that we allow our Marines to behave
out in town or even in the space out of
a fear of doing what seems to be
unpopular or being what you just
described those are the ones when I saw
squadrons suffer you talk about but
steel Patil's getting disbanded things
like that it wasn't because they were
getting beat at the point of friction in
combat it was that things that happen
inside the organization and that
leadership tolerated and end up leading
to what they were afraid of in the first
place anyway which was that they were
viewed upon is a leader who couldn't
lead their team and the greatest risk
that I saw in leadership in the Marine
Corps was allowing the people around you
to behave in ways that you knew were
wrong but the fear of looking on par
being unpopular by getting involved in
those things because they weren't cool
or whatever they were were the undoing
of the more leaders in the marine corps
that anything that ever did in an
airplane or as a commander in some sort
of tactical situation so I went through
this and to be quite honest with you I
cheated I pulled a maneuver on my troops
that allowed me to come at this from an
angle that they could not argue with and
when I used to teach the young officers
I called this the trump card the trump
card I had the trump card in my back
pocket if you wanted to argue with me
that you wanted to do this thing or do
this behavior or be or or act in a
certain way you wanted to do that and
what you were saying was hey Jocko
you're kind of a pussy because you don't
want to do this or you're not going to
allow this or you don't want us to do to
act in that in that way my trump card
was real simple and real straightforward
and it won a hundred percent of the time
it was the ace of spades
and what I would say to guys is so what
you're saying what you're saying is you
would rather do this behavior and risk
getting in trouble and not go to war not
go to combat because you'd rather do
this behavior if that's where you're at
fuck you I don't want you on my team I
don't want to be associated with you I'm
here to go to war I waited my whole life
to go to war that's what I was born to
do and to have you put that possibility
at risk because of because you want to
do some behavior one night one little
thing that you want to do and you're
talking to me like I'm a bitch you're a
bitch don't don't even bring that up to
me again
that was my trump card I got a text the
other day from one of the guys that used
to work for me and he said he said hey I
was thinking about what you told us
about behavior and he sent this little
quote to me I told him I said if any of
you do anything that prevents us from
going to war I will never forgive you
and I will hate you forever and I
laughter you know because I don't
remember everything that I said but that
right there that's to me is the ultimate
trump card oh you'd rather you'd rather
go out and get drunk then go and fight
al-qaeda that's what you rather do
that's what you're telling me right now
and who can argue with that you can't
argue with that and and you know what
guys wouldn't argue with that the team
guys well you know what they want to do
they want to fight and go to war okay or
there's some there's there a small
percent of course that don't really want
to do that but the guys that were with
me that's what they wanted to do so that
right there is the trump card and it's
the truth
that it's the absolute truth I don't
care about anything else
there's enemy there's bad guys there's
there's a group of human beings on this
planet that wanted
our way of life and I wit I have the
opportunity to go and hunt them down and
kill them and you're gonna take that
away or you're gonna put that in any
kind of risk effort not happening not
happening moral courage neck section an
effective leader willingly takes on the
risks which come with military
responsibilities in that light the
greatest failing of a leader is a
failure to lead to steadfast rules apply
first in situations clearly requiring
independent decisions a leader has the
solemn duty to make them whether the
subsequent action succeeds or fails the
leader has made an honorable effort the
broad exercise of initiative by all
Marines will likely carry the battle in
spite of individual errors so you make a
call and look if you mess up a little
bit don't worry there's 250 other
Marines that are making decisions and
they're gonna the majority those
decisions are gonna be okay we got you
second in action endo mission based on a
failure of moral courage are much worse
than any judgment error reflecting a
sincere effort to act so not doing
anything is like the mortal sin errors
resulting from such moral failings lead
not only to tactical setbacks but to the
breakdown of faith in the chain of
command proper training education and
concerned leadership are the keys to
instilling the qualities of creative
ability military judgment and moral
courage in the minds of all Marines
next section training good tactics
depend upon sound technical skills these
are the techniques and procedures which
enable us to move shoot and communicate
I made a little note here move shoot and
communicate in the team is that way you
always hear it I hear it backwards right
you hear shooting even communicated
right I believe that is correct
Marine Corps please adjust this we need
to shoot first we need to flip down
cover fire so we can move we're not
gonna move shooting communica we're
gonna shoot move and communicate that's
what we say in the teams I'm just I'm
pretty sure that's what the Marine Corps
means as well we achieve technical
competence through training we build
skills through repetition training also
instills confidence in weapons and
equipment it develops the specialized
skills essential to functioning in
combat
one of the ultimate aims of training is
speed essential to speed is the
requirement for accuracy speed without
accuracy may be counterproductive and
causes more damage than in then in
action whether Marines compute firing
data practice rifle mark marksmanship or
weapons gunnery rearm and refuel
aircraft repair vehicles stock or
transport supplies or communicate
information the speed and accuracy of
their actions determine the tempo of the
overall force training develops the
proficiency which enables this effective
combination of speed and accuracy all
the things you're talking about here
this is this is really the first time
this tactics
gets into tactical components of the
things these individual Marines are
supposed to do but something this that
was mentioned earlier that that set the
stage on this was what this pulls from
the first doctrinal pub in the Marine
Corps is pub one one tack one is called
war fighting and that is the unifying
thing that ties every Marine together is
the understanding that you and it's
really all the things you just been
talking about
you are here as a war fighter first of
all why would you do anything why would
you expend any energy or take any action
to do anything that could potentially
undermine your ability to do that
whether it's getting drunk on a Friday
night because it's it's what the dudes
are doing what the bros are doing to do
anything that would undermine but it's
also the common belief system that we
all have that that's what we do we are
here to fight wars period and every
single thing I'm going to do whether
it's putting gas in an airplane pulling
the trigger
or or memorizing how the logistics train
whatever it is you are here to be a
warfighter and the only way any of this
works is that common belief that all
Marines have that that's why you're here
and that's what you do and it guides
every single thing you do but without
that first understanding of what it is
that we are none of this other stuff
works you can't get to pub two and pop
three and pop six if you don't
understand what it is that we are and
that's I think that's why they were
describing all the other thing pulls
from that over writing understanding of
what you are and now what we're fighting
tactically it could take a thousand
different forms there's a thousand
different things tactically you can do
to be a warfighter I just think it's how
many organizations we work at where what
they do is the thing that they do I do
logistics I do mark but they don't
actually understand what they are and
the tactical application of what you do
unless you understand what that fits
into it doesn't doesn't do anything in
the end just think the idea of a war
fighting being what we do is sort of
driving everything is the coolest it's
the coolest thing
yeah and it's one of those things as you
just said if that thread gets lost by
someone that's out working on vehicles
if that thread gets lost by someone
that's delivering fuel if that thread
gets lost by someone that is computing
firing data then the whole thing off all
and that's the same in any organization
if we lose track of the underlying theme
and thread of what it is we are trying
to do we can fall apart and who's
responsible for making sure that happens
that did that that that doesn't happen
that we understand what our underlying
core mission is that's us as leader
Slater's continuing small unit training
should focus on proficiency in such
techniques and procedures as immediate
action drills battle drills and unit
standard operating procedures practicing
to reach technical proficiency applies
to all types of units whether a section
of aircraft executing air combat
maneuvers a maintenance contact team
repairing a vehicle under fire and
artillery gun team conducting
displacement drills or a rifle squad
conducting an in stride beach breach of
an obstacle we develop and refine these
measured measures so that units gain and
maintain the speed and accuracy
essential for success in battle staffs
like units and individual leaders must
train to increase speed and accuracy
staffs increased speed by accomplishing
three things first by obtaining and
organizing information to help the
commander and themselves understand the
situation boy this is like every this
should be printed on the walls of every
staff organization in the US military
second by understanding the commander's
decision and Court decision and
coordinating efforts to focus combat
power to achieve the commander's goal
and third by monitoring events
maintaining situational awareness and
anticipating and and and adapt and
adapting to changes as staffs trained
they increase accuracy by becoming more
proficient both in their respective
areas and in functioning as a team
that's what the staffs are trying to do
and notice that if you're in a staff you
better know what the commander's goal is
you better understand what that intent
if you don't understand what that intent
is if you don't understand that goal is
you are completely lost and if you're a
commander and there's any doubt in your
military mind whatsoever that your staff
doesn't know what your intent is and
what your goal is you better make it
crystal clear Field Marshal Erwin Rommel
Rommel knew the value of speed and
accuracy for his staff when he wrote a
commander must accustom his staff to a
high tempo from the outset and
continuously keep them up to it if he
once allows himself to be satisfied with
norms or anything less than an all-out
effort he gives up the race from the
starting post and will sooner or later
be taught a bitter lesson allow yourself
to be satisfied with the norms allowing
anything less than an all-out effort you
give up the raced from the starting post
that's what I'm talking about now can we
burn people up absolutely yes can we
burn ourselves out absolutely so you
what you have to know you what you have
to learn and what you have to understand
is you have to understand and learn when
you're going to conserve energy and when
you're going to go on the attack you
know that's that's Rommel talking and
and that sounds cool but trust me and
I've seen it we and I know you've seen
it in the military plenty of commanders
that they lose touch with their people
and they just burn them out and they
have horrible command climates and more
important they're they become
ineffective at executing their mission
yeah that's the real problem
continuing the speed and efficiency of a
unit to depend not only on the technical
proficiency of its individual members
but also in large part upon its
cohesiveness such cohesion requires both
personal personnel stability and solid
leadership training should also prepare
Marines for the uniquely physical nature
of combat living and caring for
themselves in a Spartan environment
confronting the natural elements and
experiencing the discomfort of being
hungry thirsty and tired are as
essential and preparing for combat duty
as any skills training the point is not
to train individuals on how to be
miserable but rather on how to be
effective when miserable or exhausted
yeah think about that for a second we're
not gonna do this so we can survive
these difficult environments we're gonna
do this so we can thrive and take
advantage of these situations the cold
in Korea we're not gonna train for that
just so we can survive the cold we're
actually gonna use it to destroy our
enemies you talked about a little bit
earlier about leaders that will just
they'll lose sight of what they're
trying to do and what they'll do they'll
just push really hard and it's not that
they're pushing harder than their other
counterparts it's that they don't
understand when and why they're pushing
hard they don't know when they should
build up the reserves and when it so
they just go hard because they know
going hard we should go hard and it
isn't that they're going harder and they
burn them out is that there's no
connection to why they're going hard to
what they're actually gonna try to
accomplish in that training and that
disconnect of why they're doing what
they're doing versus what they're doing
and I've been in units where the leader
just we just go hard and a lot of people
are like what the hell are we doing and
nobody knows and those units will fall
apart
before they actually exceed their
physical capacity to do things whereas
other units can actually you can you
actually go harder if they understand
why so that thing you really want to do
if you can make the connection to the
reason they're doing it you can go as
hard you want and it's not that going
hard that burns a units out it says
having no idea why they're going hard or
when they should go hard those are the
units that burn out here's where you can
run into a problem with this attitude
oh hey we're just gonna go hard 100% all
the time you don't know you're not
you're you're you're utilizing your
reserves out of the gate that's what
you're doing
yep and so that's a problem and what the
problem is where where a leader is even
more inaccurate in their assessments
than they think is that it's the it's
the idea that I've talked about of the
the guy that's leading PT and when
you're leading PT PT is kind of fun
because when I'm leading PT guess what
we're doing we're doing pull-ups because
I'm good at pull-ups right that's what
we're doing and so we're gonna do a ton
of pull-ups and if you're not gonna pull
ups PT sucks for you and by the way I
didn't tell you when we're gonna stop I
didn't tell you how many were doing so
who were doing pull-ups
you should be happy cuz I'm happy and so
you miss you miss calculate how much the
guys can actually take and there's a
decent chance that they can't take as
much as you because they're not leading
it that's why when you put subordinate
leaders in charge it allows you to more
closely and accurately judge how much
they can actually take and by the way
they'll push harder if they're running
it they'll actually go harder they'll
give you more if you let them run with
it if you think you're gonna lead from
the front and and whip them to keep up
with you you're wrong you will not get
the same mileage out of them as you will
if you say hey you take this and run
with it so be careful they're young
first lieutenant Rommel out there
back to the book likewise training
should enable us to take appropriate
action in any environment and at any
time this readiness includes operating
during inclement weather and periods of
limited visibility we must make terrain
weather and darkness our allies if we
are to gain advantage and deliver
decisive force at a time and place of
our choosing we can neither anticipate
nor appreciate the inherent friction
that these natural factors produce
unless we experience them next section
training and educational methods
that's such that's here that's boring
title number one that's the only that's
the first boring subsection we've got
training and educational methods okay I
don't know if we expect a little bit of
higher standards there is no single best
approach to developing tactical
proficiency however any approach should
be adaptable to all Ashlyn's and grades
the environment should be one that is
challenging and conducive to creative
thinking like all preparation for war
training should reflect the rigors of
that environment the following examples
may provide some tools for developing
tactical proficiency in Marines number
one professional reading and historical
study because of the relative
infrequency of actual combat experiences
in most military leaders careers Marines
must seek to expand their understanding
through other less direct means the
study of military history is critical to
developing to developing judgement and
insight it enables us to see how
successful commanders have fought
through and fought through the
situation's they faced not many people
can do it instinctively few possess the
rare native ability to think militarily
even those few can enhance their
abilities through study and practice
what general matters say no just think
the whole time thinking about all I was
thinking about in the last two minutes
was mattis yeah and he said he said that
every situation he saw I had seen it
before he wasn't afraid of any situation
because he'd prepared for it that's
right that whole time mattis just his
approach to personal in his personal
library of 5,000 books and you you take
5,000 and and I imagine that when
Madison them he's reading them with this
incredible depth yeah not as a homework
assignment it's not a homework
assignment he's not 21 year old first
lieutenant David R Burke saying okay
well I've got to read this before I can
go grab a beer with the boys what am i
enabling learning objectives so I can
I'm down real quick so I can move on to
something yes no he's reading that with
the level of death and understanding
that he he not just that but he puts
them all together he wasn't afraid of
any situation yeah because he had
prepared for every possible situation
that was out there through study of
history because guess what the stuff is
all happening at least one other time
before they maybe twice you know what
I've admitted to a couple times in the
recent past and you've been with me when
I've admitted to it there's nothing that
I like more than something that I didn't
expect or that seems problematic or
chaotic that's what I want like that's
that's when I that's when my that's when
my adrenaline just gets a little bit of
a release because when I've seen it 90
million times it's like cool I'm down
like what will handle this problem but
man I like it when something comes at me
that I'm not expecting I love that I've
loved that for a long time and part of
the reason is because it's just an
experience once again it's it's an it's
an opportunity to put some of that
creative muscle to work and that's fun
continue on historical studies provide
the most readily available source of
indirect experience in our profession
these studies describe the leadership
considerations the horrors of war the
sacrifices endured the commitment
involved the resources required and much
more as if that's not enough and much
more these studies include biographies
and autobiographies of military figures
books on specific battles Wars and
military institutions unit histories
after-action reports films and
documentaries group discussions helped
to expand the insights into leadership
and battle that we have gained through
individual study and this is a solid
ninety-eight percent of what this
podcast is biographies autobiographies
books on specific battles Wars military
institutions that's what we do here
and like Liddell Hart said when you
study about war you're gonna learn about
life that's why that's why so many
people listen this podcast that our
first lieutenants or Colonels or
generals they listen because they go oh
yeah I couldn't take that same theory
and apply it to my business to my family
to my life professional readings and
study are not solely the responsibility
of military schools individuals cannot
afford to wait for attendance at a
military school to begin a course of
self-directed study military
professionalism demands that individuals
and units find time to increase their
professional knowledge through
professional reading professional
military education classes and
individual study it's on you know you
cannot wait for your battalion your
regiment your squadron to train you
doesn't you cannot wait for them and if
you wait for that you are just wasting
so much opportunity to be so much better
at this job tactical exercises tactics
tactical success of alls from the
synthesis of training and education the
creative application of technical skills
based on sound judgment exercises enable
leaders to practice decision making and
individuals staffs and units to practice
perfect collective skills exercises also
serve to test and improve tactics
techniques and procedures immediate
actions battle drills and combat
standard operating procedures and by the
way I've been changing state it keeps
saying standing operators just saying
standard I'm saying standard rewrite
this thing
an exercise should serve as a units
internal assessment of the quality of
its training and education and not as
grading criteria for higher commands oh
that's a nice little thing we're not
grading you for higher commands we
actually just want you to learn like you
know those schools where they say well
you're not gonna get graded here and it
sounds super lame and it was like well
think about if you if you said look what
what I really want you to do here is
learn and I remember saying that when I
was running trainer be like listen man I
just want you to be ready for combat
that's what I want I'm not looking to to
write you up or anything I just want you
to be ready for combat bro that's what I
want
like if that could have been a good
introduction to lieutenant Dave Burke
he's like listen we don't worry about
where you're gonna break out in this
class what I want you to do is learn and
understand what we're saying
to you that's hard to do that it's hard
it's so hard to do that I think of how
many things that I gaffed off early in
my career simply because I didn't
understand that it was gonna make me
better
I just didn't make the connection in my
mind that doing this not the motions but
actually listening and learning to
whatever it is that they were teaching
me would make me better and more
successful if you told me that there was
a it was a competitive thing there was a
ranking and a grading and a measurement
that you were gonna get I'm all in oh
yeah I'm all in why wouldn't I
but the number of things that I was I
just and I know how many young leaders
are out there listen it's not just in
the military and the business world to
young leaders are listening to this I
ignored so many early in my career it
just took me a while to figure that what
you just described I just didn't
understand it and I wish I could go back
and tell second lieutenant Burke just
pay attention yeah just pay attention
this is gonna pay dividends you're gonna
be able to cash in on this down the road
and your peers are gonna wonder what the
hell is going on with you because you're
gonna be so far out in front of where
they are if you just pay attention to
this stuff one of the things that you
can do to make that
and in my opinion is you you actually
have to try and put yourself into the
scenario that you're being that you're
being taught that you're reading and
I'll tell you you can hear it when I'm
when I'm reading when I'm reading with
the old breed man my brain is there it
is there when I'm reading one sort of
walk when I'm reading the coldest colder
than hell when I'm reading excursion in
hell my brain my mind is there I'm
putting myself right there that's what
I'm doing when you get taught something
when you hear something put yourself
there put it in to put it into your
world and put yourself into that world
being able to do that that earlier you
can start doing that the better
comprehension you will receive from
whatever it is that is being bestowed
upon you and that that's it's hard to do
it's hard to do and you know I'll go
talk to the young the young seals and
nowadays I mean oh you can see the kids
that are listening because they are
absorbing and they are in it you can see
it in their on their face and there'll
be a couple there'll be a couple that
are they're just not there they're like
oh you know I have to listen to another
person talk right now yeah and there'll
be a that's usually pretty small number
look but then the guys that are just
there they're absorbing what you're
saying you it's like they're gaining
actual experience okay is it actually
France no it's like they're gaining such
a closer approximation of experience
than the person that's sitting there
going ah I got a look take notes so I
can get good do good on the quiz it's
because they've made the connection and
I remember avoiding stuff like this
because I don't have the time for that
if you actually make the connection
think of how much faster it goes and how
much
easier it is to go through it when you
actually make that connection to you and
what it is you're trying to learn it's
easy and the avoidance of that and in
the end the resistance to doing it is
the thing that actually makes it more
difficult than it needs to be and that's
that's what I did I think I'm like what
am I gonna get from this and I just
resisted and when I'm I remember even in
college spending a couple years in
college like we're gonna do all this
work the hell am I gonna do those work
for when I figured out that doing what I
learned from doing the work and how much
better it made me the work was ten times
easier making that connection putting
yourself inside of that and look these
books are actually where somebody's
looks really good I missed it some
really good learning that are really
well written with the old breed was the
one that was the trigger for me early in
my career I wasn't I was probably a
junior captain when I like a young
captain so probably be four years in the
Marine Corps and I read that that was
one of the first big light bulbs for me
was that book yeah sledge and just holy
cow just reading that book that was one
that turned me back into paying it
that's got me on that bat path and I
don't get me wrong there are times that
I veered off that that book for me was a
big turning point yeah and for me
obviously it was about face reading sure
the first time and and the first time I
read it I read it because it was the
most awesome war story or or I shouldn't
say the most because I you know you
can't compare because with the old breed
hmm tough tough to outdo colder than
hell though yeah
colder than hell when the Marines when
the wounded starving frostbitten Marines
are rolling back into base camp after
escaping the envelopment and somebody
calls out fall in and they start
marching back into camp and the other
Marines line up and like salute him I
mean come on yeah
so but about face for me there's
definitely the first time I read it was
like an awesome war story and then the
second time I read it was like hmm
there's there's a little bit more here
they're here
then I originally saw and then as you
read it five times you go oh man that's
a gem oh oh
I never my intuition is completely wrong
and this is clearly the right way to do
it so yeah putting these putting
yourself into these situations is a is a
way I think we'll we'll start to open
the door on how to read this stuff where
it will have the most benefit and impact
for you yeah back to the book exercises
also test the ability of units to
sustain tempo for an extended period of
time since victory is rarely the product
of single actions the ability to operate
and sustain combat effectiveness over
time is important knowing when
hostilities will cease is a convenience
denied the combat marine equipment must
be maintained and people must be
sustained with adequate rest nourishment
and hygiene until they accomplish their
mission tactical exercises can range
from field exercises to command post
exercises to tactical exercises without
field troops field exercises conducted
by units of any size involved involve
all unit personnel working together to
learn test and refine their collective
battlefield skills such exercises can be
general in nature or they can be
detailed rehearsals for specific
upcoming missions command post exercises
are largely limited to commanders and
their staff their purpose is to
familiarize the staff with their
commanders personnel personal
preferences and operating styles as well
as to exercise staff techniques and
procedures to review a particular to
review particular contingency plans so
for those of you that are in the
military sometimes the leadership the
staff can rehearse and practice and do
exercises as if there's a as if there's
a
their maneuvers not revealed or working
and even though they're not tactical
exercises without troops provide
tactical leaders opportunities to
exercise judgment while permitting other
unit elements to conduct training and
education on their own there are two
approaches to conducting them the first
method provides a leader an opportunity
to evaluate a subordinates ability to
perform in a given scenario boom
scenario based training role playing you
don't need anybody you don't need
anybody in the field you can make it
happen
this method places students in an area
of operations and provides a situation
upon which to plan an executed task for
example establish a reverse slope
defense the aim here is to exercise
tactical proficiency in the siting of
weapons and the use of terrain the
second method also places the student in
an area of operations that provides a
situation but gives them a mission or a
mission order for example prevent enemy
movement north of route 348 the aim here
is to exercise judgment after walking
the ground the students must first
decide whether a defender it's act
supporting their conclusions with
reasoning the reasoning is then
discussed and criticized this approach
encourages students to demonstrate
ingenuity and initiative they have free
rein to employ the resources as they see
fit to achieve the desired results so
just putting people in scenarios and and
then well equally important is
discussing and criticizing and asking
people why they're doing what they're
doing why they made that decision
figuring out how they're thinking of why
they're thinking yeah that part that
last part of hey why did you do this and
not the why did you do this not that why
like you're wrong and I need to know
what you're you know like hey what were
you seeing that made you think to do
this and look if it turns out that it's
just tactically a mistake and you know
problem no no factor this stuff is free
you're not really moving people around
you're not really spending gas it
none of that is happening you can do
this all day long but it's the leaders
that actually ask hey why were you doing
that what do you see in there that you
start to that's also I remember being
asked as a young slightly to having
senior flight leads more often than I
it's like what are you doing and you
don't want to answer and you're like I'm
sorry I'm I said something good the best
guys ever flow hey man what did you see
they're like well I saw this and that
and it's often they weren't seeing it
and that ended up becoming that built my
confidence up that hey it's like you
were describing earlier my brain
actually is working pretty good what I
lack is the confidence to take action on
what I see cuz I'm afraid he's gonna
think there's something wrong with it
and the takeaway from this and we see
with companies all the time is they
think training is elaborate and training
requires all these things it doesn't
require anything you could sit at a
table like this and have the
conversation and if you have a strong
enough relationship go hey man what were
you thinking there when I started to
figure out that my instincts were pretty
good and I understood it better than I
thought and I started to build my
confidence I started to contribute to
the organization better and that comes
from the leaders when they say what and
the critique and then I was willing to
be criticized I wasn't defensive up
being criticized I was actually
listening to their point of view as well
it's not that hard it just a little
humility from leadership would go well
would you see man why that's pretty good
I know I didn't see it like that those
conversations aren't that hard and
they're free they're free next section
wargaming war games can be a valuable
tool for understanding the many factors
that influence a leaders decisions
morale enemy and friendly situations the
higher commanders intentions firepower
mobility and terrain are only a few of
the decision factors included in the
play of war games in all these
simulations from the sand table to a
commercial board game to a computerized
Simula simulated routine should be
avoided the less familiar the
environment the more creativity the
student must display sand table
exercises tactical decision games and
map exercises present students with a
general situation mission orders and a
minimum of information on enemy
and friendly forces sand table exercises
are especially suited to novice
tactician
they present the tomato rain in a
three-dimensional array where as a map
requires interpretation both map and
sand table exercises enable students to
conceptualize the battle deliver their
decisions and issue orders to
subordinates afterwards students discuss
their decisions and are critiqued the
decision the discussion should focus on
making a decision in the absence of
perfect information or complete
intelligence those are again these are
things that are free free you can do
with your business you can do with your
team you can do with your platoon next
section terrain walks terrain walks
introduce the realities of terrain
vegetation and weather terrain walks can
be conducted in at least two ways the
first method provides students with an
area of operations a general situation
and a mission as in sand table and map
exercises students describe their view
of the battle choosing one plan the
group then begins to walk the terrain
according to the plan the group will
then encounter two unentertaining
obstacles while the instructors
introduce enemy actions into the play of
the problem in this way students must
contend with the disparity between
actual terrain and vegetation and maps
as well as the chaos and uncertainty
generated by enemy actions that
invariably occur in real world
operations - just think of all the ways
you as a business owner can employ that
right there playing the bad customer
playing the good customer I mean there's
so many ways to do this the second
method involves the first-hand study of
historic battlefields
we gain a special Vantage on battle by
walking the ground and seeing the
battlefield from the perspective of both
commanders we gain a new appreciation
for historic historical commanders
blunders often such blunders seem
incomprehensible until we see the ground
only then can we realistically consider
alternative courses of action that the
commander might have pursued and
interestingly a National Front right now
we've kind
we're starting to prepare some
historical battlefield walks and terrain
studies that we're gonna offer up to a
small number of clients so that will be
they'll be awesome some of the sites
were checking out right now gonna be
great next section competition exercises
should provide realism the means to
achieve tactical realism are competitive
free play or force-on-force exercises
yes whenever possible unit training
should be conducted in a free play
scenario this approach can be used by
all leaders to develop their
subordinates it affords both leaders and
unit members their opportunity to apply
their skills and knowledge against an
active threat free play scenario so when
you're setting these up this is a little
this like a little tiny thing I remember
doing this so we'd have certain areas
we'd be training on let's say a base
somewhere and there'd be some area that
we weren't allowed to go into you know
for whatever administrative reasons hey
there you guys aren't allowed to go over
there because that's the whatever and
the common thing would be the okay guys
just to admin note you're not allowed to
go over there and I hated that because
it ruins the free play snare it puts in
everyone's mind that well you know this
is this is like lame so I would say hey
guys yeah you can go wherever you want
by the way
Intel indicates that there's IEDs
heavily planted in this area and then
sure enough we plant some fake IDs right
on the border and they might hit one but
they wouldn't continue that direction
so as you're setting up scenarios try
and make them as realistic there's
always constraints on a real battlefield
don't make a madman make them real yeah
what's an admin constraint like what
like like like this game does it
indicate that it's a game in their mind
it's a game in their mind so you might
have let's say we have a let's say this
we're going to a an urban terrain
village and the army says hey this one
building we got over here
the it's unsafe and we don't want your
guys going in it and so instead of me
saying okay guys it's free play except
for this building it's not safe so don't
go in there and everyone goes that's
kind of lame right whereas if I say hey
guys do whatever you want
this building right here heavily ie deed
Intel reports indicate that it is
heavily ID'd and if you go there you're
you are almost guaranteed to take a
casualty and then in the doorway
I put an IUD right a fake ie D and it's
like yeah so it just keeps the mindset
in the game yeah we did that in aviation
all the time we'd go out to arrange net
lists or whatever and you'd have part of
the range and some of the part you
wouldn't have cuz another squadron was
training there and most of the admin
briefs were hey we don't have this range
in this range stay out of there cuz you
know you're not supposed to be there the
other guys in their training below X
altitudes to avoid them the good flight
leads would say we have a SAM ring here
from this surface-to-air guess which
guess which scenario had more violations
of that range the one we had a SAM ring
where you died in in the mission you die
and get colored out and you wouldn't get
to fight anymore or the admin violation
they would just say move to the north
you're in violation of and making a
realistic isn't that hard there's a
whole bunch of places we would fly all
the time Rick you can't go there why
that's Iran yeah they have this system
here you don't want to fly there not
because it's an administrative border
totally and 95 percent of the time that
the one that you would violate would be
you're not allowed to be there why would
you just not because we don't have it
today and whatever okay or you put a lot
live threat there and guy was like I
don't gonna I want to get killed there
you go make it realistic free play
exercises are adaptable to all tactical
scenarios and benefit beneficial to all
echelons whether it is fire teams
scouting against fire teams sections of
aircraft dueling in the sky do you get a
little bit any like that don't you do or
battalions or companies battalion
squadrons and marine air-ground Task
Force operating against one another both
leaders and individual Marines benefit
leaders form and execute their decisions
against an opposing force as individual
Marines employ their skills against an
active enemy through free play exercises
Marines learn to fight as an
organization and deal with a
realistically
phoE next section is about critiques a
key attribute of decision-makers is
their ability to reach decisions with
clear reasoning critiques elicit this
reasoning critique solicit this
reasoning process any tactical decision
game or tactical exercise should
culminate with a critique the standard
approach for conducting critiques should
be should promote initiative since every
tactical situation is unique and since
no training situation can encompass more
than a small fraction of the
peculiarities of a real tactical
situation there can be no ideal school
solution critique should focus on the
students rationale for doing what they
did so there's it's like you said I'm
not gonna say Dave you chose this method
that method was wrong I mean okay are
there exceptions to that yeah you could
do something that was tactically unsound
and then we talked about it but you made
a decision let's talk about why you made
that decision what factors did a student
consider or not consider in making an
estimate of the situation were the
decisions the student made consistent
with the estimate were the actions
ordered tactically sound did they have a
reasonable chance of achieving success
how well were orders communicated to
subordinates these questions should form
the basis for critiques the purpose is
to broaden the leaders analytical powers
experience level and base of knowledge
thereby increasing the students of
creative ability to devise sound
innovation innovative solutions to
difficult problems and I used to explain
to my guys when I was running training
that the goal was not to the goal of
training was not to put their brain in a
box it was to open up all those doors
and allow them to make decisions that
they that aren't that on standard
critique should be open-minded and
understanding rather than rigid and
harsh I'll read that again critique
should be open-minded and understanding
rather than rigid in horse this is the
big tough United States Marine Corps
telling everyone that your critiques
should be understanding yes why because
mistakes are essential to the learning
process and should always be cast in a
positive light
mistakes are essential of learning
process and should always be cast in a
positive way imagine if you applied that
to your children
the focus should not be on whether a
leader did well or poorly but rather on
the progress achieved in the overall
development win or learn as I talked
about in warrior kid you're gonna win or
you're gonna learn
that's the marine course and we must aim
to provide the best climate to grow
leaders damaging a leaders self-esteem
especially in public therefore should be
strictly avoided and that's exactly what
you talked about Dave you talked about
the good the good leaders that would
build your confidence but I'm sure along
the way you had guys that were like the
hell were you doing Burk for sure look
you're your best tool to figure out how
to not make a mistake in combat is to
figure out the mistakes you made in
training that's the best thing you can
do is figure out all the things you did
wrong and with that sort of relied on
over time what you actually wanted to
get to is guys willing to admit the
mistakes that they made that people
didn't see mmm look and that's that's
magnified in a single-seat airplane most
people didn't see a lot of what a lot of
my mistakes people didn't see or you
could certainly cover them up if you had
a squadron where guys were willing to
pay you didn't see this but I screwed
this thing up by myself if you get to
that point now you're here to place
where that squadron is literally inside
on the idea of hey I'm just here to make
everybody better I'm not afraid of
admitting any mistake that I made and
I'd be a squadron and you see that the
senior guys that would just crush the
junior guys and guess what they did with
all those little mistakes they would
hide them all all those little things
that you might not hear about that that
you're never gonna see I'm not gonna
volunteer and I'm not gonna get it
crushed again and you know who you're
hurting we got the whole team your crush
on the whole team and if you can get to
a point where your guys are offering up
errors that you didn't even see
now you're at a place where you know
you've got a team willing to to figure
it all and how do you think that teams
gonna do in combat how do you think that
team's gonna do in the real world but
yeah Manny all the time ego gets in the
way you see these guys and what they
really want to do is they want to look
smarter in front of everybody else and
they're gonna do it at your expense and
yeah that that feels good for about 30
seconds I crushed this guy in public Oh
guess what you actually hurt yourself in
the long run you hurt the team in the
long run and it's so obvious when you
talk about it but it happens all the
time who looks at a leader that crushes
someone in public and goes wow that was
it was awesome awesome that was so cool
with T you bruiser we would because when
you get done with a run whether it's a
land warfare or urban or whatever you
debrief and then the cadre debrief you
and you know the cadre usually just rips
task units apart but task unit bruiser
we would hammer ourselves so hard that
the contraband or another run yeah and
this is how they close out this little
section a leaders self-confidence is the
wellspring from which flows the
willingness to assume responsibility and
exercise initiative so every moment that
you are cutting down a leaders
confidence you are crushing their their
willingness to assume responsibility
take ownership and exercise initiative
this is what you need them which is what
you absolutely need them to do crazy and
here is the conclusion in this
publication we have explored themes that
help us to understand the fundamentals
and to master the art and science of
tactics from the study of our
warfighting philosophy we have gained an
appreciation for the requirement to be
decisive in battle to accomplish this we
must clearly visualize the battlespace
gained through gained situational
awareness recognize patterns and make
decisions intuitively we have also
discussed ways we can gain advantage
over the enemy and force him to bend to
our will we also
how to be faster in relation to the
enemy to adapt to changing conditions to
cooperate for success to exploit success
and to finish the enemy finally we
discussed how we can begin to act on
these ideas during our training for
combat
the ideas presented in this publication
have implications far beyond ba
battlefield tactics and the doctrinal
way we think about warfare they also
influence the way we organize using task
organization and flexible command and
control relationships and the way we
equip ourselves for combat waging war in
maneuver warfare style demands a
professional body of officers and
Marines schooled in its science and art
when asked why the Marines were so
successful in Operation Desert Storm
general boomer replied the thing that
made the big difference on the
battlefield is that we had thousands and
thousands of individual Marines
constantly taking the initiative
the young Lance Corporal would take a
look see something 75 or 100 meters out
in front that needed to be done and go
out there and do it without being told
as I read through the award citations
from Desert Shield and Desert Storm
this theme reappears time and time again
that aggressive spirit comes from being
well-trained and confident in your
professional knowledge and here's how
they close this thing out
everything we do in peacetime should
prepare us for combat our preparation
for combat depends upon training and
education that develop the action and
fall essential to battle
and that wraps up MC dp1 tack three
tactics everything we do in peacetime
should prepare us for combat everything
and let's just take that one step
further that everything that you do
matters it matters and I know that
everyone's not necessarily preparing for
combat but we are actually preparing for
life for the next opportunity that we
are going to see and we are going to
seize and we are going to exploit or the
next obstacle or the next crisis we have
to be ready and everything we do should
prepare us for that so don't take it
easy and don't slack off be ready to
aggressively attack or counter and get
the upper hand and then be ready to
exploit repeatedly until you finish the
enemy that's what we're doing here
all right good review I did not think
this was gonna take four podcasts yeah
what's probably eight to ten hours I
guess I guess maybe around eight hours
but that is eight hours well spent and I
hope that I hope that people listening
to this clearly my number one priority
is I hope that the folks that are gonna
be going out on the front lines to
protect this country can get something
and take something away from from this
series of podcasts kind of it's been
awesome having you here Dave to hear
your perspective from the Marine Corps
to hear your perspective from just how
closely these things relate air-ground
doesn't matter it's like it's the same
thing it is its leadership its tactics
they're all related Jack did you think
we would go that deep no I didn't and I
actually I learned us much just
listening to it again and that for me
was probably the most fun as me just
sitting here hearing you say the words
that I've read before a couple times and
making the connections to a whole bunch
of things that I hadn't made the
connection on before this was I mean
look this was awesome for me to be here
and of all the the books to be talking
about Marine Corps tactics that's that's
good to go yeah so check echo Charles
yes speaking of being prepared for
combat for life sure I know you're
pretty you're pretty into that you know
oh yeah big you got that uh dot 5o Cal
Desert Eagle
sure was that your first handgun that
you got oh well you know technically
yeah yeah that's a good I bought a bunch
of them together so yeah so the first
one that I paid for in sight for yeah
desert eagle but it can't really took
offer to come in so into you know before
it came in I got other ones you know I
bet it's cool to shoot that thing yeah
well you know oh yes I did it was that
thing was awesome yeah preparedness
that's part of your preparedness
yeah very practical um because I also
have a refrigerator so you know someone
attacks me they hide behind the
refrigerator boom I'm prepared you see
them saying oh cuz you got the desert
eagle a greater penetration that you
need yeah for the in house scenario you
know scenario what if you don't have a
weapon what can you use that okay so and
I think about this too a lot not a lot
we'll just say some of the time where
yes you can be prepared with weapons
most the time you're thinking about like
if you want to think about what you
think about a lot it's like Hawaii
five-o you know Mario Brothers
no matter Mario Brothers yes nonetheless
you can be prepared with someone
parallels you echo nonetheless Charles
yeah just saying yeah and I know what
you want that's that's a quasi important
point to because I don't say
nevertheless some people try to tease me
and be like oh yeah you see you
nevertheless but I don't say no that's
never letting hairs I must be there
anyway like I was trying to say you can
be prepared with weapons desert eagle or
otherwise but what if you like don't
have ammo the weapon fails or you simply
don't have the weapons I know like we're
encouraged to have your tools on you at
all times they get it but are they on
you at all times
they should be yeah but let's say you're
in the shower let's say you're picking
up your kids from school no gun zone
what if you're in the airplane check yep
there you go to an airport past security
you see I'm saying through good
scenarios anyway it's possible is what
I'm saying so then what do you have and
I'm not saying like you need to be Bruce
Lee a hoist Gracie or something like
this but don't have nothing don't go
from level 10 prepared to level 0 in one
pass of the security checkpoint you see
I'm saying so what can you have you
could have the jujitsu
it's true it's absolute - anyway so yes
we're doing jujitsu and the good part
about this is like this preparedness for
taking jujitsu is fun beneficial
health-wise and also therapeutic so
mentally fun is or mentally uh conducive
did you see the big fight at Disney
World
negative Disneyland did you see it it
was on YouTube
yeah oh like a fight fun yeah big fight
no but at some point somehow some dude
just walks up and puts a dude to sleep
and then walks away yeah a doctor yes
come incognito walks up behind and puts
them to sleep lays him down walks away
yeah so that's jiu-jitsu that's that's
that's one month of jiu-jitsu and I'm
sitting here thinking you hear the
argument well you know this I enough too
much time to invest and how good can i
really get like you trained for a month
and you can put someone to sleep oh yeah
trained for one month just two times a
week and I'm not saying you will you'll
be effective against another G so you're
not gonna be well you compare yourself
to the guy who doesn't know any digit -
which is a lot of people I know there's
the question when are you going to be
attacked it might be in a month but it
might be in two years in two years you
could be that much more prepared for the
situation and on top of all that benefit
of just this pure self-defense aspect
you got in better condition and you
broadened your view of the world you
know you became a better human being
your perspective is better you see the
thread in all things yes you will
so you do so we're doing jiu-jitsu by
the way oh yeah Viktor and and it makes
sense when people go in the first day
second day and they get addicted because
they see the power whether it's
demonstrated on them or if you just like
I have a six-year-old daughter currently
she's six so I'm not saying to do this
but I'm saying this is an example of how
it can be kind of fun and empowering so
I taught her the rear naked choke it's
fun to do that if you teach kids who are
responsible with it you don't need I'm
going to school and choking out
everybody I understand actually you need
them not doing that yes correct you have
to explain to them that this is not for
school
unless it's a serious self-defense yes
and there's a whole you know protocol
event
but so we're at a party on koi and you
know we're like hey you know you're
talking about this talking about that
and my daughter she wants to demonstrate
the rear naked choke and most people if
they don't know about the rear naked
choke they're like oh I got your six you
know you're not exactly right
and so like all right well just let her
put it on you and you know like if you
can resist it cool man you're right and
did she put someone to sleep no the
thing is you you know when you're going
to sleep even I mean how's this my
wife's nephew put my wife's brother to
sleep before but he was like 14 15 years
old but nonetheless so these kids or
even adults whether they'll learn these
these moves first day and they'll become
addicted because they know the power the
power that a sixty six-year-old can get
in one day by the way ninety one day
twenty minutes really and they have the
potential to put an adult to sleep crazy
whether it be a desert land or other
basis yes sir
so one you trained you sir you're gonna
need a key if you're doing gear
recommend key and okey so if you're
doing key when you're doing key get a or
Jinky from origin main comma in America
main America best keys 100% by far
actually yeah and maybe you're a
patriotic person maybe you just like to
support the economy in this country well
years ago they took the economy away
from Maine they took it away yeah they
sold it overseas we are bringing it back
so if you want to change you Jitsu and
you want to at the same time support the
economy of our country go to origin
Maine and if you aren't training
jiu-jitsu or you're gonna train
jiu-jitsu and you got an origin key but
you don't want to wear that D to the
store because you want because you don't
want to be that guy right when you get
the store
have you ever want to get to a store
negative not even I have not either yeah
I thought kid with the kids with door in
the store more the key my daughter's
something weren't my youngest daughter
has worn her key actually I think all my
kids have worn my keep my kids have worn
their
straight up out to dinner you know and
there were little kids and stuff just
bringing them from the straight where
they're geese the holgie belt tied
they're all tied everything you know I'm
not gonna disrespect that geek lovin but
yeah my little daughter even right now I
mean she's 10 but you know if we gonna
go grab some food afterwards after
jiu-jitsu class we might you know she
might be in her Guinot factory on yeah
oh good I know that kind of that kind of
improves their it improves their posture
yeah yeah and there went our Agee oh
yeah they're kind of got that that that
I could see that moved self-esteem yeah
when they're wearing yeah in their mind
they're walking around they're like hey
they see what I'm wearing yeah there's
no mistake to see what I'm wearing
basically I'm training I'm over here
training what are you doing that's what
my little ten-year-old daughter's
walking around saying that's good you
stop saying it verbally but giving that
a implicit message to the world I'm over
here training what do you doing eating
doughnuts that's what it looks like
alright so yeah if you don't if you
don't want to wear your geek you can
wear jeans should we have jeans at
origin we have t-shirts at origin and we
have supplements at origin to help your
physical and mental and cognitive power
preparedness ski be prepared because
really that's ready yeah so so krill oil
joint warfare these are for your joints
and general health because you know
curcumin that's in joint warfare mmm-hmm
so there's anti-inflammatory stuff in
there really good stuff this will keep
you in the game physically like your
joint like man and again I said this
before where you know when you think
supplements were thinking creatine mmm
stage act you know implement gains
because of the supplements a base debate
this is what I think you've been trying
to say for the last three years or
however long mm-hmm the the foundational
supplementation should be focused on
joint health yeah you know what that's
like
hmm so and I might have said this before
maybe maybe not whatever but it's true I
might have been not listening to you yes
so you wouldn't really know yes yes I
get it you're not wrong on now and but
this is still correct it's like when you
take these
creating protein things it can be looked
at is it like this if you don't take the
foundational joint or joint stuff stuff
that'll keep you in the game can you
overpower no it's like you're watering
like if you have a plant or a tree it's
like you're watering the leaves you say
no you wanta the roots the roots allow
anything to grow on top dirt and then
it's gonna be you know based on hard
work and discipline and consistent all
that stuff but you what are the roots
the roots are strong bright you're gonna
stay in the game same thing with your
joints mmm 100%
Dave last time you talked about the
disciplining go pill which I know you
take prior to to quote you from last
time prior to anything but I also know
that you pound quite a bit of the
discipline pre-op powder drink dude you
the go in all forms has become my go-to
supplement use it everywhere I do and
you know we're kind of kidding around
I'm I'm dead serious if I want to be in
the game mentally which I do for kind of
everything other than watching TV right
because we don't need to be anything
right we'll be honest with you no wrong
TV no I'm in full agreement watching TV
for me which is a relatively rare event
that's a boy that's a social obligation
no I was gonna say not to go into your
personal life but you were telling me
the other day when you watch TV it is
not for you it is it is for your family
it is it is like a watch yeah after you
like cool I'll sit down and watch this
and I'll for me
it's like time to sleep it is yeah a
little power nap I will I will sleep
through I take my kids to movies my wife
and I will take our kids movies I have a
100% success rate of sleeping through a
majority of these movies all right well
this whole movie important question that
are you gonna take discipline go or
otherwise when you're watching the new
Top Gun movie oh there's a whole
situation there's a very strong chance
that I will because that will probably
the first movie not just because I want
to see what happens because I am sure
I'm gonna get 10
or more questions about that movie and
it'll completion of it and I want to
know what are you in it like what
accuracy question you're not in are you
did you advise into on it or anything
maybe Shh all right so you're kind of in
it maybe I'm not in it you won't see me
you see my name and the credits but are
you asking me if I was involved in it
maybe he's doing top-secret missions for
Hollywood over here the only reason I
would say maybe is that I wouldn't be
able to a lot I wouldn't be allowed to
tell you based on when I contribute to
that movie right yeah so he'd be allowed
to know he could tell you but then he'd
have to kill you
no I tell them in the mean anyway so yes
this Wingo while watching the new toxin
it's called maverick by the way any time
I want to engage in something I'm taking
go oh yeah
which is basically every waking hour of
my workday and not when I'm watching TV
yeah cuz that's that's sort of the thing
that I was getting to is you know you
might drink hey I'm thirsty I'm gonna
have a have a glass of water
hey I'm thirsty I mean you eat a coke or
sprite if you're a human person that
doesn't care about getting after it but
if you're a if you're a person that does
care about getting after it you can get
oh I'm kind of thirsty I'm gonna have
some discipline go and I'm just gonna
get up on step and I'm gonna stay there
yes because there's no overload of
caffeine by the way there's no there's
very little caffeine fifteen milligrams
per scoop yeah and it doesn't take much
to you don't need to be pounding five
six cans of it it doesn't take much to
get on the step yeah I'm with know
there's with you there if you do need
protein then you can get some from milk
which is milk
disguised as protein well actually
there's protein in the form of a dessert
yeah and so you can check that out we
keep talking about how good it is and
yes it is that good and warrior kid milk
you can get for the children's that you
may or may not have
formulated and of course tea another
thing that you can drink all day long
hot in the wintertime cold in the
summertime so there you go that's origin
maintain calm also Jocko has a store
it's called Jocko store anyway this is
where you can get shirts discipline
equals freedom you're gonna represent
the path while you're on the path you
know rash guards hoodies hats
try not try Finn no we're gonna get dry
fit stuff by the way oh we are sure it's
yes for working out overwhelming
recommendations for a dry fit I got a
dress recommended that that you finally
because I've been asking you that for 14
years before I even knew you I was
asking I know and you know what yeah
yeah well and I get it and you were you
were right and here's here's why I'm
arriving to that conclusion even on an
emotional level okay so one of our
friends and I wish I could I could go no
no I wish I could remember his name give
me a dry fit sure representing his team
and it's like it's it's a cool it's a
red one so I'm like oh yeah cool I don't
really wear a dry fit but hey man cool
so one day I put it on and I was like
man this thing is good like it fits good
it like heals gets lighter
it's like breathe see I was like man I
could wear so then another time I went
and worked out in it I'm like okay
that's when I became a believer in the
dry fit I always thought they just
didn't look good or something like I
don't know you just thought they didn't
look good yeah check see that's the big
difference between you and me I go form
over I go I go function first yes and
you go looks well yes yeah all kind of
like I'm white men can't jump
remember that movie you'd rather look
good and lose than the other you know
obviously look bad and win or something
like that
Woody Harrelson shark kinda like that
anyway so yes I'm like okay I'm a
believer fully so boom dry-fit coming
soon more have dry-fit stuff this
political freedom also lightweight
hoodies flex fit hats and trucker hat by
the way
check taco store calm you don't forget
to subscribe to the podcast if you've
forgotten for three years four years if
you've forgotten to subscribe to the
podcast put it on your list of things to
do in the coming year subscribe to it
and don't forget to subscribe to the
warrior kid podcast so that your little
kids are just aligned with your thought
process isn't that a nice thing yeah
Dave your kids do your kids absorb dude
let me think of a way to write the
answer this ask this correctly without
being offensive do your kids listen to
Uncle Jake or you which one gets the
higher priority the the question is is
they listen to both but the success rate
that Uncle Jake has is significantly
higher yeah
that's what I would say I can't do this
experiment with my kids because my kids
don't differentiate between these these
things they just they're just you know
they that's what they get like your
youngest when she first heard the word
kid podcasts or like ask Uncle Jake and
you'd be like brother that's just you
yeah yeah like she knows what's behind
the curtain area you know Marie sure
it's ours someone said someone asked
Marie is a female black belt that we
have at the gym and and someone was and
she mean we spent a lot of time on the
mat for the last ten years or whatever
and so and I've given her I gave her
some advice over the years right little
counseling sessions about things and
it's worked out really well for her and
anyways someone else asked her a
question and she was answering it and
the person goes got you you sound just
like jockle podcast in Mariko's i don't
listen to d'arco podcast mm-hmm you know
then she told me that story I said well
you don't listen to John Barnett you
listen to me you listen you've been
already hearing this stuff for 10 years
you know there you go
so the children sometimes it's it's a
little bit of a hit on the ego because
you think well I want my kid to listen
to me yeah but you know what I want my
kid I want my kid to listen to someone
that's making sense it's only a hit on
your ego if it's more important they
listen to you than for them to be
successful
I would rather miss like what you just
said echo I would rather my kids listen
to me and lose then listen to someone
else and win
so we gotta watch out for that don't
forget about a warrior kids soaps Irish
Oaks and ranch comm where young Aiden is
making soap on a farm in California you
use that soap you can stay clean you
know YouTube channel yeah we do have a
YouTube channel if you're interested in
the video version of this podcast if you
want to see how much Dave Burke looks
like Tom Cruise yeah which is not zero
like there's some overlap there there is
what's the overlap there all their hair
you're taller I think you got you know
yeah well good so you can check out what
Dave look you can also look at the
videos that echoes super proud of overly
proud of you can put comments on those
things and he reads them I read him huh
I read the little comments on there
usually someone writes a clothes jacked
you know and someone else writes didn't
take the good in the bad I'm not saying
I read the comments not saying I don't
read the comments but I am saying from
time to time a one I do read a comment
across various platforms I will say this
when someone does say echo is or looks
jacked the number of A's and Jack has
been steadily increasing so that really
you're getting more jacked
so I post I posted a couple things on it
on the gram sure the Graham yeah
the Instagram and I was reading those
comments those confidence are almost
worth reading aloud some of them are so
funny yeah especially when I made a
salad on Instagram in three minutes it
takes three minutes to make this salad
and the some of the comments that people
were making about I can't believe you
eat chicken Frontenac and you had to
come in and give me fire support on that
one well yeah a little bit yeah so yeah
those were those were those were funny I
think I might make a look I think I
might make a little video of me reading
some of those comments I was laughing
out loud when I was reading those
comments yeah yeah those yeah very good
one was reading milk oh yeah dairy it's
like a Lincoln it's like I was drinking
formaldehyde it was just some people
were just getting crazy but I liked that
some people were just so super stuffy
man saying that sounds cool man
yeah and I mixed my I mixed my salad
dressing in a used water bottle yeah you
mix all that stuff in these I know I by
the way I'm pro used but people like you
know some people were like there's my
APA yeah you got it you're gonna yeah
you know that's a good thing though
overall if those things get in them it
this is for real like how quick you made
a set because I make a salad similar to
that like just super basic in boo boo
where some people they think wait you
make a salad every day like bruh making
a salad is a big deal you gotta chop up
the thing and a spoon is the most
gourmet thing honest yeah not even yeah
three minutes right
oh yeah and then guess what I didn't eat
a salad I did have the can of chicken
open pre-opened yeah there you go three
minutes 10 seconds easy money but no
because most people they're like oh wait
I have don't have time or whatever so
what are they gonna make a freaking hot
pocket in the freaking my you know which
is horrible for yeah is that worse than
salad dressing mixed in a water bottle
I think yes it can chicken yeah man so
and that's really the point right there
it's like organizing the Guild Wars bass
video yeah and people were like you're
gonna get carpal toe whatever that's
Connell and someone else in your posture
is gonna break down I mean wait what row
is so wobbly why will you you get part
couple carpet I don't know I don't know
but I type all the time I don't have it
so what does that mean oh wait you need
like an organ ama keyboard or something
like this anyways funny stuff
that's uh going on psychological warfare
it's an album with tracks you can get me
talking to you about moments a weakness
flipside can viscom that's dakota myers
company for artwork to hang on your wall
to keep you on the path you can rock
that and then there's on it calm slash
Jocko yes
good stuff on there kettlebells that's
the number when I think on it I think
kettlebells but they got a lot a lot of
good stuff on their rings as well that's
known that one's a key if you don't have
rings get rings 100% definitely on it
calm the books I have for you or your
kid three warrior kid two warrior kid
one these are the books that will get
your kids on the path man look like you
know how we reading this the whole time
Dave like man I wish I wouldn't read
this like type of thing when I was
twenty
well when you were nine you wish you had
the warrior Kid books I guarantee it and
you know what if you didn't have when
you were nine you're gonna wish you had
him when you were 38 true story hundred
somebody's somebody asked me an
interview the other day what does it
mean to be a man
right okay fair enough question and I
said oh it's not an easy question to
answer in a quick interview but I wrote
a book about it it's called way of the
warrior kid in fact I've written in a
whole series about it it's about what it
means to be a man what it means to be a
person because there's girls and boys
that read that book and the lessons are
how to live a good life as a human being
so you might want to check those out and
then Mikey in the Dragons how old is
your youngest five
how does Mikey and the Dragons come
across
he loves that book and what he does now
and we when we bust that thing he
actually is spending more time with
water kid now mmm is getting order you
know what he holds when were reading
Mikey in the Dragons he's got a sword
yes so he's super stoked cuz cuz he's
got a sword I like all the little notes
I get and of whatever the fear was you
know it's like and I told him to be like
Mikey and face the Dragons and and he
stood up and jump in the pool or he
stood up and got up on stage or whatever
the case may be
so yeah miking the Dragons my boy is -
mmm oh he'll be three next month and you
know I read it to him and and you know
my daughter's well and cool good of
course they do you know they like that
but they can look at the pictures - you
know cuz the pictures a lot more vibrant
you know then the worry kid ones I'll
catch him not often but everyone said oh
I'll catch him acting he cannot read
he's too you know but he's acting like
he's reading it but he's really looking
at the pictures you know how kids
sometimes do that they look at the
pictures and then I'll just assign a
story to every picture you know and he's
doing that he's like or the dragon came
and it was just a baby dragon or
something like this man but that's a
testament to the pictures in there John
Bozak representing coming on strong
speaking of pictures discipline equals
freedom Field Manual that's a book for
adult humans so the things you want to
know about little I've been getting
after it the audio version that is on
iTunes Amazon music Google Play and
other mp3 and then extreme ownership and
the dichotomy of leadership leadership
books I wrote with my brother leave
babban that you can apply to everything
in your world
we got a chillon front which is our
leadership consultancy and what we do
there is solve problems through
leadership Dave and I refer back to it a
hundred times the companies we work with
that's what we do we get them on a path
where their leadership is aligned and
when your leadership is aligned your
company will absolutely win and when
your leadership is not aligned guess
what's going on your company is losing
go to a tional on Front
dot-com if you want us to come and work
with you
we got a EF online because training for
leadership is not a one shot one kill
deal another topic that Dave and I
talked about you don't just read a book
you don't just sit through one seminar
and go oh cool I'm a great leader now no
you never say that and so we made the
online training to reiterate and embed
the concepts of leadership that we know
to work embed those things into your
brain and into the brain of everyone at
your company EF online.com we got the
muster coming up the next one is
September 19th and 20th and Denver after
that December 4th and 5th and Sydney
Australia if you want to come register
now or you will not be able to come
because it will be sold out go to
extreme ownership comm for details there
and if you need people if you need
leaders at your company you can get
former Special Operations and former
combat aviation leaders that are leaving
the military that have been trained and
have been proven with their leadership
skills and you can hire them to come
into your company and utilize their
leadership skills to help your team and
your company win go to EF overwatch
dot-com for that and if you feel like
there's a bunch of topics that we
haven't really covered in depth enough
yet and you want to continue to discuss
them with us and you can find us on the
interwebs we're on Twitter we're on
Instagram and we're on nine freezin Bach
echo is that echo Charles Dave is at
David R Burke BER ke and I am at Jocko
willing echo anything else Dave anything
else negative thanks for coming out man
it is so good to be here
and thanks to well thanks to all of our
armed forces that are out there right
now that are standing on that wall and
keeping us safe and to our police and
law enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics and EMTs and dispatchers and
correctional officers Border Patrol
Secret Service all the first responders
thank you for standing inside that wall
and keeping us safe here at home and to
everyone else that's out there try to
remember how the Marine Corps wins the
Marine Corps wins by constantly taking
initiative by chasing the enemy down to
the last man and killing him and
throwing his remains into the river
that's how you fight do that do that
with your own personal Wars do that to
your own personal weaknesses and do not
delay in the attack the time is now so
get up and go get after it and until
next time this is Dave an echo and Jocko